wow Ethan great moves keep it up welcome
everybody it is the H3 podcast off the
rails January 10th the year is
2024 yes we've arrived in the new year
and this is our second episode of the
Year thank you guys for being here nice
to see you welcome back today we have a
phenomenal show that is sponsored by
expressvpn and gamer
Subs love them we love
them um we are going to be doing our
we're going to be doing the Gypsy Rose
thing and and you know I this topic is
so interesting
I know close to nothing about it I
haven't seen the Hulu show which I'm
assuming is why there's such a frenzy
about this whole thing right it's got to
be definitely part of it yeah okay was
that show super popular it was okay yeah
the ACT they were the last line of
defense the ACT is the last line of
defense thank you Joe so what's
interesting to me is
not just her story it's the way that
people react to her too she has
like there was like
a people got the idea that we were going
to do this segment and they go and they
there's so many people they go leave
leave Gypsy
alone you get
that and then you get the
um the
um she's just not that in what what do
you get I guess it's just lots of leave
Gypsy alone kind of stuff it's you know
uh and then like oh you're exploiting
this girl by talking about her really
strong opinions the thing that that I
thought was funny is
just when she got out of prison
she immediately has been doing like
she's loving it Well yeah if there's
anything that she's made abundantly
clear it's that she wants people to hear
her story yeah so this whole like leave
leave Gypsy alone and then meanwhile
she's going on like every show yeah let
her yeah how about let tell how about
let her decide what shows she wants to
go on to you don't need to you know what
I mean let her actually be like a human
being you don't she doesn't need all you
to be her handlers let her have agency
finally
exactly and she's not going to kill
again right right you know what I mean I
mean obviously I at the age of3 podcast
can't prom hey and hopefully she's not
going to kill again she's not going to
kill again we do not support murder here
at the podcast we do not for the record
and neither does
gypsy and CPS of her saying that bra
very brave she she's against murder now
absolutely so she's changed her mind
killing think she was you'll see she
regets killing her mom yes murder like
interesting murder it was murder in
there I wonder though I do wonder if uh
chat is thirsting for me AB said stop
they're saying you look good yeah I
agree I agree sometimes I walk past you
and I don't realize it's
you I don't know what you're talking
about um thank
you uh
so I'm actually looking forward to
learning about it CU I don't know and
you know what guy people go like I can't
believe you're talking about Gypsy dude
that's what we do this is my bread and
butter also everybody's talking about
it's a huge story and I don't know
anything about it almost so I'm
fascinated it's also like true crimey
which is my you know that was the
crime so you leave gypsy alone how about
that turn the tables on you yep she's a
human she sure
is so um that's going to be the main
thrust here we got a PowerPoint on
that we've also got tons of stuff to get
to at the top of the show here uh
because we've missed so much so let's
start there I'm actually looking forward
to excuse me whenever I open the stream
because I like to look at chat
occasionally you hear it twice for a
moment chat is right so let's see here
we've got um oh thank you Charlie for 50
gifted that's so nice of you
hey here's an announcement that should
excite people this happen on the see you
next Tuesday that happened yesterday for
members check this
out is there anything to announce yet
about Jeff Whit being The Bachelor yes
well kind of I I'm pretty sure it's
happening he's on board we're starting
to to um lay the groundwork trying to
set the that was me yesterday saying
Jeff Whit is going to be our next
Bachelor can you believe it can you
believe it
[Music]
folks we've got the best Bachelors don't
we folks I mean Jeff is the most
eligible bachelor on the internet maybe
in the world
frankly and he is coming here
a man who wants to find love he's ready
for love and he wants to find
it so if you've got eligible
bachelorettes out there far and wide
this isn't just the podcast we need the
whole world to be participating in this
this is a huge opportunity this is Jeff
Whit he's tall too I don't know if you
guys know that if that comes across he's
pretty tall mhm he's like he's like 6'2
probably right yeah it's around there
yeah you guys don't you might not not
even notice that until you meet him so
he's got like pretty much everything
going on for him
okay it's a little vain Jeff just to
accept
that
Ethan and I'll say this about Jeff after
I've gotten to know him better I can I
feel like I can say confidently that he
is really when it comes to um his
interactions with women a true
gentleman I really do believe that he's
a respectful king and a true gentleman I
really do believe that
so that's going to be launching around
or no our plan is to launch it on
Valentine's Day which
is
next next month on the what day 13 or
something 14 so we're going to basically
start we have a lot of groundwork to do
there basically but uh we're going to
bring announcements out soon but get
hyped because this is
happening minimum age is 25 so start
finding all your bachelorettes out there
25 25
plus get them ready get
that I'm excited it's going to be a
frenzy don't you think I mean Jeff would
oh yeah
yeah come
on come on so that's exciting come on
man come on
man uh I got this weird autism on
Twitter dude the Twitter ads lately are
nuts like obviously they're hurting bad
for sponsors and that which when when
I've been on Twitter recently it's
literally I see just straight up like
out of the closet Nazis just like
wishing death on all Jews and that's
just like the that's like cool
now which
I must say I liked Twitter better before
when I didn't when Nazis weren't
comfortable just saying like yeah I was
never a huge fan but um yeah I got
downgrade I think the censorship in that
case was probably good thing yeah yeah
at least for me as a user I don't want
to see people wishing me
death right so I'm using Twitter a lot
less and
I'm this is the new theme song of of
Twitter so the ads they've been getting
have weirder and weirder the epoch times
what is this look at this this first of
all just look at this
image an image of a child being
vaccinated and then just autism like I
understand what they're doing here this
is crazy the autism vaccines causes
autism people are running ads on
Twitter the expensive meta analysis of
25 autism studies could shift the focus
of research into the cause of
autism definitely for the record not how
autism works it does not come from a
vaccine with peace and love that is not
how it works study reveals shocking
findings on causes of
autism
so shout out Epoch times yeah so are you
not familiar with the what the epoch
times is no what do they do there well
uh it's a farri uh media publication but
specifically it's um part of the uh
Fallon gong I think it's called Uh yeah
the Chinese like um New Age religion
cult thing I don't I've heard that name
I've heard that name you know do you
know uh it's called sheny young I think
uh China before communism the like
ballet you see Billboards for it all
over La all the time so what was China
before communism uh was it like feudal
feudalism yeah Imperial China um but
it's a lot more than that um the the
cult uh which is illegal in China which
is why it's mostly based in the United
States and um is sort of a the epoch
times is like their mouthpiece
essentially and yeah they're really
nuts it's like Scientology it's
like Chinese Scientology basically
that's so interesting is the uh local
performance related to that Dan you're
talking about the ballet thing yeah yeah
that's run by no way yeah that's
a cult thing yeah the main W so if we go
to a show that's like that's a cult show
uh in a sense yeah I mean it also is
just like a ballet thing U but saw
people behind it are a little nuts here
um so here the Fong gong they known for
opposing Chinese Communist party okay
Ethan you probably get down with that
that'll get you kicked espousing anti-
evolutionary views opposed to sex
homosexuality and feminism re rejection
of modern medicine
um among other views described as Ultra
conservative it sounds like they don't
like anything yeah nothing good call
which I have personally connect with so
like so yeah that last one about the um
uh rejection of modern medicine kind of
uh is exemplified by that ad that you
saw well you know when I I did see that
ballet and the thing that really gave it
away was that it starts when this uh
child gets a vaccine and then it's the
story about this young this boy with
autism and special interest is dancing
yeah they're also apparently they've
been big uh supporters of like the Q
andon stuff uh on anti vaccination
misformation there you go they seem
pretty in touch with American culture
they're at the Dolby dude know we should
go so wait this is like a real thing
yeah
yeah but then is it Cy or is it just a
cool show uh I've never been I I don't
know here uh watch the trailer actually
don't claim me bro that looks sick Bro
yeah I want to go they're like autism
cause they've really low during like
intermission or during scenes when you
can't really hear vaccine cause
autism yeah it just looks like a look at
that these know how to put
on a show
goddamn I joined that cult hell is this
what it's like good vibe this is
exactly what China was before uh
communism actually everyone was
living in a musical dancing pettes all
the time yeah doing ballet through the
air
chass well okay so uh shout out to
Twitter who's really become such a Cess
poool I
frankly and I'm s it's even worse than I
thought it could be at this moment do do
you guys spend time on on Twitter still
yeah and do you see what I'm talking
about or is it just my Fe I do I well I
don't see a lot of promoted stuff but I
just see like crazy like Nazis posting
weird ass like Jewish conspiracies
like straight up specifically this week
where all this stuff going on in New
York synagogue the synagogue oh the
synagogue stuff is mad just so crazy
wait the tunnel thing that is
really funny I just saw it's not funny I
just like what aspect of that is not
funny it's not funny that people are
with are getting like 50,000 likes and
millions of use people saying that it's
a child sex trafficking operation oh I
hadn't considered uh that's what I'm the
blood Li okay got it it's it it's funny
that a bunch of yish speaking guys dug a
tunnel because they W to go to I think
that's awesome that's so sick they
they're like Co we're tunneling
into
the I about they they were like they
were expelled from their from their
group from their Temple or whatever and
so so and they wanted to get back and so
story yeah so they were sneaking into I
thought they were trying to break
Co um maybe I that was the story that I
read uh the other day sounds like one of
the Twitter conspiracies right before we
went live I saw a an edit that said
Teenage Mutant Ninja Jews of them of
four guys crawling out of the uh out of
the sewer yeah I mean that's that's not
that funny that's fine I don't like the
blood light I mean they were crawling
out of the sewer I saw the video
too yeah just like the turtle that's
what I'm
saying mhm the turtles did Blood liel I
think I found it actually I sent it oh
thank
you so okay yeah I mean this this isn't
this is a fair joke teenage M ninja
Jews this is an AI image for sure yeah
it looks like it that's cool four four
Orthodox Jews peeping out of a
manhole
yeah I'm sorry it's objectively funny
that that sucks that people are turning
it into that though well why why are
they going in the tunnels are they
trying to they're tunneling into the
synagogue for one reason or another
somean were banished from the synagogue
what I read is that covid laws were they
weren't allowing people to go to uh
places of Warship so they wanted to get
in but either way they were just
tunneling to get into the
synagogue which is funny yeah if I had
time over I might do that too you know
make some tunnels under La that' just
Minecraft in real life pretty much
pretty
much yeah but most people are doing like
bake Heist and and these guys are
just like we just want to pray bro let's
go yeah tunnels are in lately have you
guys noticed
that really in the the girl didn't the
girl get shut down I think she actually
got in trouble yeah yeah she did she
didn't have a permit but she says she
will continue anyway yeah she says she's
going to continue how do you get a
permit for that there's no permit for
that she says as long as you stay under
the actual house foundation she can do
it she can go as deep as she wants
that's what she says but I doubt you you
got to make a deal with the Teenage
Mutant uh Ninja juice what yeah zoning
rights I'm all for it though keep going
girl keep digging find that diamond yeah
mhm so shout out to the Jews and
the and uh the gypsies
Rose now what I don't know oh here okay
thank you Cam this is not this should
give it away that it's a cold
[Laughter]
thing like this is a this this is a dead
giveaway rightly
C so it's a really the show takes a
really weird twist telling you telling
you oh
God uh
uh is there anything to say about
um Jake
dittle no what more is there to
say he's ethered
dude well he's gone you think he's
done after
that I mean if he he should listen to
your advice that's all I'm GNA
say no Ethan that's not how that
works yeah the thing is like
again I I would feel bad for him if he
didn't have so many opportunities to
pull off the highway on this one oops
you know he just he just kept going head
head on man but you know one thing I
will say that I don't like seeing people
do is uh question questioning the
validity of his illness that I would I
would appreciate not seeing because
that's what what he did to me and we
don't do that here on the H3
podcast and it's just not it's not
pertinent like to anything yeah I mean I
guess people think it's ironic because
he he claims he has chronic L I'm sure
yeah and I'm sure he does yeah I'm sure
yes I 100% believe that he went through
everything he said he did yeah chronic
lime is an interesting phenomenon though
apparently it's not
recognized by the medical field as a
real illness
right uh how I mean but you know I
believe
him well what I was reading it seems
like it was it kind of seems like it's a
catchall that people use for when they
can't get a clear diagnosis of something
else they know something's wrong but
yeah apparently that's not an actual
recognized uh
diagnosis which is yeah so but but
anyway
um just you know what I mean like Dan
said he got ethered that's what Dan said
and so let's just let's let just let
Jake uh be sick on his own yeah well
go be sick by yourself
please and it makes me sick if
he if he made a heartfelt apology I
probably forgive
him sure yeah yeah I
mean you know I don't hold a
grudge well sometimes you do sometimes I
do for this yeah this is this is a this
is a forgivable sin for sure this this
could be a learning moment for you Jayo
yeah
pusses yeah but anyway that's all I want
to say just you know what I mean just
leave the guy alone you guys I not I I
haven't seen people harassing him I
haven't seen evidence of that but I just
see but don't do that but like let's not
let's just not go there please thank you
just leave Jake
alone
forever which is what he'll be
forever not true he has a significant
other who's really seems really nice mhm
all
right
uh I was on the Jumbotron at
Cincinnati uh hell
Bengals shout out to the huge Bengals
fans here more of this especially
cam do you hate oh he's not here I was
about to ask him somebody put me in the
chef hat on the jumbo how it's so good
that's awesome so unfortunately
there was a there was a tiny short video
clip of it too but it was the very end
cuz I think they saw it happening and
tried to record it but they only caught
the last second so so we know it's real
yeah I'm just wondering did they use the
audio of you talking about cook like
were they doing a let him cook like meme
or
something here's another one so they use
multiple shots didn't didn't this happen
with uh the jokes music like someone was
playing it on the Fields uh oh was that
well I forget if that was the Bengals or
not was it the same Bengal guy there's a
d there's someone deep in in the
organization shout out Bengals
awesome I'm a Bengals fan now all of a
sudden but anyway I love this guys do
keep doing this let's disrupt Society
show them that we're out here we live in
a society shout out to my bangal bro
also there was another uh Bang
Bros a deep plan a Sleeper Cell at the
WWE check this
out this guy's holding up a picture of
me doing the goofy face why you got why
you would you the goofy
face you know what I mean why do you got
to show that picture I wrestled the
bear here is here they are again oh he's
wearing Teddy fresh too I recognize the
sweater
Legend um and here's this is wrestling
by the way yeah of you who don't know
on um it's still real to me Dam it here
he
is I saw other
ones yeah there was one other uh there
was one with like a sign right was it a
different oh here someone with a dink
doink that's awesome this is a oh it's
the same person yeah yeah shout out dink
dink keep holding keep
holding soon drop the
pick up the
D dude this man did two crypto scams he
did the dink D and then people still
bought his how does that happen and
people are still support him this man
went to he's looked his fans in the eyes
and he says you you and then
people like cool man you're you're the
guy funny thing is Logan wrestles in the
WWE now so uh a reminder he is very good
at it too I'm not even going to hate on
him oh the ding Tong's right behind them
you wow yeah oh did he see
it to say this probably atone hanging
right there you think he blames me for
that because he got apparent allegedly
he was mad during the live
show remember Jeff said that he was
pissed
oh really or Mike said he was pissed or
something oh well yeah I mean of course
he is I'm getting at him why wouldn't he
be hey hey hey uh Logan what color is
the dink D
mascot got him again I really hate to
say this I think there's someone hanging
right there oh God okay we were trying
to forget that moment
Zach uh girl gets kicked out out of
whatever podcast these guys are the
whatever has got to be the worst one of
all whatever dude this guy has no he has
no personality he has no Charisma he has
no Insight he's probably the least
interesting person a lot best effort and
he has the same conversation every
episode the same what so what's your
body count like what's your so what and
what's your body count and what's your
body count what's your body count and
would you date and how what how rich do
you think a guy should be to to get
married to him and how how much money
does a guy need to have to get married
it's like every episode why are
we watching this you know what a
detail I recently learned about him that
made it all make sense is that I I guess
occasionally he'll come up on the show
but he is a massive World of Warcraft
player I know that yeah course of course
wait how do you know that huh how' you
know that uh appar I I heard from
somebody that had watched a decent
amount of the show that he's a huge wow
nerd yeah he's there's clips of him
bragging about his like characters and
stuff to like as soon as I heard that I
was like listen no offense brother but
no offense brother but if you're trying
to be like the alpha male yeah you can't
sit and I play a lot of video games I
love it but priorities like you can be a
hardcore wow gamer or you can choose to
have a romantic love you can have a love
life you can have both oh wow I can
confirm that yeah I say that with peace
and love of course cuz wow is not a part
if you want to be into wow that's like a
16 hour per day part job part-time job
wow you
know well what do we think about that
he's a wow player that hates
women a
unicorn I think Wow's probably just you
know I didn't expect them to be like him
all I have relationships with women
exactly so you're bored make this
conversation less boring go ahead so
this girl I think came on with the
intention of trolling him and he gets
really butt hurt I'm waiting how often
do you think about the Roman Empire
Brian that is that your best effort sure
in any case you're not it's honestly not
a bad question like Brian I would like
to I would like to know Brian frankly
it's a better question than the dumb
you've been asking everybody he's
dodging because that that number is high
let me tell you right now that's in the
that's in the High da no I think he he's
he's thinking about killing bores in the
uh the forest that's that could that
could count yeah that could CU I think
of like ancient civilization yeah Kings
on a Bor hunt Bor hunt yeah that's how
how Robert bar barathan yeah yeah rest
in
[Laughter]
peace particularly adding to the
conversation you've been disrespectful
this entire time you're entitled you're
that's how tilted you're getting dummy
rude you have Tik Tok brain you cannot
stay focused we've only been live for an
hour and a half or so I'm going to ask
you to leave okay so get up get the
out dead damn dro the ham you
seemed really upset about having to
leave too wait hold on listen to what he
says now
okay good LU on your dead ass podcast
though on my dead ass podcast you
do only fans you
generate bro you your whole career is
talking to my fans girls theti they made
you yes dude he can't even like commit
to misogyny it seems like he's like
looking down as she's there like he's
nervous and then as she leaves he calls
her a God he is such a
loser I wonder if we could get on a call
I'd like to debate him the whatever
guy could probably go on his podcast I'm
not going on I'll I'll du him in World
of War let's reach out to whatever guy
whatever man I'll buy him a rare mount
or something yeah sweeten the
deal yeah oh my God what good they're
all gone so you're bored make this
conversation less boring go ahead bro
and so he clipped this and uploaded to
make him look Alpha he's got the alpha
music I'm W is really bananas how often
do you think about the Roman Empire
Brian
Brian we're in your walls Brian oh hold
on there
was he posted this clip on his main
account the whatever one how many how
many engagement did this
get 34 million that's probably from her
right cuz her response went viral but
this had 12,000 likes so she responded
and said this is hilarious because he's
in my DMs every other week begging me to
come back on his
show 150,000 likes she continues it's a
shame because he's actually quite polite
in person but if it's going to be his
entire stick then he's going to have
some basic concern for his guest a
4-Hour drive round trip simply wasn't
worth the heinous threats I got in my
inbox for months afterwards posting the
sauce down for Sunday he says April
18 May 7th he says I know it's super
last minute but I got a super solid
panel for tonight and we have one spot
we can help arrange a ride that's the
least your ass can do this panel will be
viral if you want to make
it uh feel better November hey interest
in coming back on smiley face new time
Sunday Tuesday 4 p.m. dude you sent her
these DMS and you still posted this like
how embarrassing can you be yeah
he just posted this on December 23rd
this convers knowing that he's been
begging her all year to come back on the
show
man that's
embarrassing well I guess from his
perspective this is good content because
he's like you got to slam her and kick
her out I his audience genuinely thinks
that that's cool you know what I mean
like that he looked cool In that clip
well what about the fact that he's been
begging her to come on the show that's
not so they can kick her out again
that's good content for
him right okay I like the
optimism uh this crusty ass host is on
every of girls DMS bro no shot this is a
fan of the show little
lyanna of the podcast is she of our
podcast should I not click her profile
do not click her
profile God out but shout out though
shout out to my friend we love you she
had a funny response though in the DMS
okay great this crusts host is in every
of girls
DMS again he literally was like you do
only fans you horror right and yeah it's
his entire
stick um let's see what's your body
count like
details blah blah blah you can would you
like to be on the show if so there's a
Sunday or Tuesday coming up that works
for you thank you smiley face smiley
face so beta
bro you know what I mean don't do the
smiley face have some
dignity she said I would rather drag my
through a field of cactuses then
go on your pcast with that insufferable
host true
[Music]
true true
true so we'll mark you down for
maybe let's reach out to Brian I think
we could it's a good opportunity for him
if it's just about content maybe just
come you can maybe find like if you just
get one clip of owning
me that'd be great for your social
media I think she was wearing a Teddy
fresh necklace in the original one for
real
the girl who he kicked
out wait what is this one oh he's
talking about hardcore wow all
right let me check this trading oh yeah
yeah so like
a go
on I don't know if this is good I was
just sending examples of him talking
about no I want to see I want to hear
him nerd
out let's hear it dude level you know
what I don't know if it's that that bad
but a level 60 right could then trade to
like a level one like you've seen you
are really connecting with the ladies on
the panel here right now where it's like
okay here's a bunch of potions here's
some Enchanted gear here's like bro you
just said potion and Enchanted gear on a
dating website on a dating show you
cannot use those those kind of language
sir no potion talk
Brian did they plant where those
flannels
cute I like the matchy matchy yeah cute
fiery or whatever um giving like
basically decking out like a
level one I love that you you're in
favor of that yeah I mean like if I bro
your show sucks so
bad what's his YouTube channel like does
he get a lot of views yeah I think these
get a lot of views I hate to say it but
I think it does pretty well um they also
like I I I hate to say this too but
people think that our shows are long
this guy is the king I heard he does
like8 hour show every single one is like
a 9-h hour marathon stream it's F how is
there that much to talk about there's
not they talk about the same it's not an
exaggeration they just thought like
what's your body count uh do you think
you know is is dming on Instagram
cheating it's just like the same rote
questions with 10 only fans girls over
and over does look like a potential I
know we made a clasp that looked like
this I think it might be Teddy fresh you
think so
legend legend could be if that's the
necklace I think it is it's one of my
faves yes for it all time awesome oh
good what is his views like uhy half a
million views uh three weeks ago that's
too much he's more popular than fresh
and fit sounds like yeah have four
million
Subs because he This Guy's in old school
he used to do pranks I remember I used
to right if you go on his Channel all
his prank videos are still on there on
the whatever podcast I used to look to
him for like content to react to so
that's why I remember the whatever and
he just made this crazy pivot into being
a misogynistic weirdo not that crazy of
a pivot I guess seeing seeing as every
single one of those prankster guys did
the exact same pivot whatever you man
wait okay I thought he had this Congress
guy or this guy got kicked out of
Congress actually loser anyway shout out
I guess we'll do our ads uh yeah yeah
and then we have uh a caller that should
be uh calling in fairly soon here I
don't think you've mentioned this yet
Fest you
guys the
fitus mar robbi I want to to
this
speech um so I'm looking forward to
talking to him I think we'll have a
really fruitful conversation I agree I'm
very excited he is among many things
definitely a
conversationalist conversationalist a
thinker nobody yeah true so anyway thank
you to expressvpn who we love them we
love
them why do we love them let me tell you
why going online without Express VPN is
like changing while leaving your window
wide open you might not have anything to
hide but why give random creeps a chance
to invade your privacy I saw a Tik
Tok dude in
Bakersfield he went into the convenience
store with his window down and he had
his lunch in the seat he comes back to
his car someone just took one bite out
of his burrito and put it back that's
you that's you with without Express VPN
that's right nobody's taking bite to my
Burrito Boy that's
your when you go online without a VPN
your ISP can see every single website
you visit they can legally sell this
information without your consent to ad
companies and Tech Giants who then use
your data to Target
you so why should you use
expressvpn you can browse anonymously
when you use expressvpn isps can not see
your online activity your identity is
anonymized by a secure VPN server and
your data is also encrypted for maximum
protection it's easy to use fire it up
click one button on the app and Bob is
your uncle as they say and the business
it works on all devices phones laptops
even routers so that everybody connected
to your Wi-Fi is
protected
um vpns they're so useful for so many
different reasons you seem like a VPN
guy I love yeah I'll use a VPN for like
um Netflix Netflix yeah my go to well
cuz in Sweden you probably need it for
something in Sweden I vpm to America and
now the opposite right I vpm back to
Sweden to see my Swedish show sometimes
there's some stuff that's not here also
with the like Swedish um government uh
online TV like the main websites you
can't access them from outside the
Sweden because they're really same same
with UK you can't access the UK kind of
government why do they care I don't know
why I don't know why they do that but I
need a vpm tags though so there you go
there's so many great reasons to use a
um a VPN it's a great service for for
everybody secure your online activity by
visiting expressvpn.com H3 today that's
expressvpn.com
H3 and you can you'll get an extra 3
months for free that's expressvpn.com
H3 thank you thank
you
AB you try how was the um the lamb that
was really good sincerely it was really
good um our marketing guy at Teddy
freshw great guy some of you might know
him um he has a halal cart M that he
made and we had him bring out and do a
catering thing for everybody and oh God
that was crazy that was crazy the
beef wrap was excellent so good oh yeah
love went back back for seconds I sure
did you didn't try the lamb though no I
I went crazy on the beef it was just so
good show the front of the shirt uh AB I
think this is a different one you didn't
get that one yeah it says I went to W's
halal cart and all I got was food
poisoning or something yeah that's what
I
said definitely hygienic back there
though I looked yeah it did look very
yeah I'll give it 24
hours anyway thank you that great that
was really good uh gamer sub you know
what I washed it down with a nice cool
that's right boy gamer up yeah oh rise
up right now
[Music]
woo there's about a million and one
reasons to drink gamer up one is that it
tastes great start there two all you
need is that it's hydrating it's got
minerals electrolytes and even caffeine
so it's a nice pickme up if you don't
want to drink coffee coffee tea or any
of those boring ass lame drinks you can
get it through your gamer Supply also
known abbreviated as gamer
sub also if you're hooked on sugary
drinks and you're trying to lose weight
you know frankly this is a really good
substitute those sugary drinks man
they'll get
you if you're having like two cokes a
day even I mean you're pushing like
probably close to 400 calories yeah it
goes goes fast
and if you're even if you're eating like
your daily amount of calories let's say
2,000 400 on top by the end of the year
you're going to have gained
like a significant amount of weight not
with gamer sub though uh we also have
our own flavor you guys might know Sigma
brain spicy Margarita it is so so so
good not and if you don't like spicy
food I make this pledge and promise you
will still like this flavor it's just a
little tingle it's a little fairy dust
on your
tongue nothing
more yeah they don't use sugar and it
tastes great it's uh it's super
affordable too it ends up being like I
forget what it was but it's like cents
per scoop yep per Bev you
know yeah it's a great uh gateway to
healthier lifestyle you know it's a
great start to the New Year get all the
benefits of drinking it there's a
caffeine free version as well if uh you
just want a great tasting beverage with
all the other benefits of drinking it
guys go to gamer subs. G and use the
code H3 to get 10% off your order and
try Sigma brain our exclusive flavor
only at Gamers subs. thank you so much
to our sponsors please consider
supporting them we love them we
do yes sir all right um it's big yeah go
ahead before we get into the heavy stuff
there's actually Wally just stopped by
to drop off if you want to bring in here
come sit next to me do you have more
yeah he has some more he brought I was
just talking about you okay so you can
try oh love
y oh it's like this sauce is insane bro
I'm not telling it's just for you just
made oh this is in first not yet sit sit
at the chair next to
him love now you gonna one yeah
sure pull that pull that mic over you're
such a coward bro you didn't eat the
lamb wait who wants a piece of lamb who
wants to try this right now I'd love to
it's not gy it's not like no
scary it's real it's real food me I'm
glad I'm glad thank you how was it it
was great it was actually fairly easy
thank you so much I was stressed in the
morning I marinated all this last night
made the rice at 4 oh my God M dude you
crushed it I'm glad come grab come come
it was
bomb so W's food truck can I grab one of
those too yes please anyone who wants
toy please in
fact I didn't say take the whole thing
oh one for Zach one for me W I already
had I had I had yours already actually I
just I like every single one who else
I'll take I'll take I had it earlier it
was delicious I'll take another though
oh thank who said that
okay this is the best lamb I've ever had
all right well what do you say to people
who say I want some of that while they
oh I say too bad too sad won not
available not yet I'm going to do I'm
going to do a real popup soon a first
IRL one one of these days this is good
cuz good practice and obviously you
won't lie to me if it's good you know
you'll just tell me straight up I feel
like what I would say if I didn't like
it is I would say it was good what but
what I wouldn't say mhm is this is the
best lamb I've ever had wow is this holy
he's always he's always
exaggerating like three tiar so you can
always back it down no I'm being totally
truthful it's on camera I wouldn't glaze
you up like this if I didn't like it
dick right it's super tender it's really
good love go
ahead that sh is busting it's so good
you don't like lamb right you don't
exactly I'm scared that it's going to be
too gy or gy what's it called but this
is bordering to it tastes like beef nice
MH good fat God delicious what is this
cut it tastes it's a French lamb chop
and then it comes in a rack so you have
to cut each individual piece the perfect
size mhm you put you dip it if you want
to put the sauce on it oh my god dude
have you always been like a chef
interested in cooking and stuff yeah
used my dad used to own a Kebab
Restaurant oh for real so my dad used to
start restaurants and they would all
just fail oh no they all just bomb and
then I would work in the kitchen with
like hardcore chefs from the Middle East
and then you picked some stuff up yeah I
picked some stuff up I got in trouble a
ton because I'd westernized I'd be like
oh can I put this on it oh for real they
just beat your ass
you you have some good kebab recipes
from your pops yep I have I stole
everything the sauce stole that sorry
Pop see you later
Bozo oh my God so hopefully when I do
the first IRL popup
soon I'll plug it yeah oh yeah I want
people to try this I support you guys
all get sick after you guys are all
Ying well the shirt that you gave me
does guarantee food poisoning oh yes
that's right that's right that's right
that's right no I can that is the
freshest most delicious meat you it's
crazy I'm going to eat every single
piece of meat on this ball I told you
love yeah I should have listened know
you're way around some
meat thanks bro of course enjoy enjoy if
you guys want more there's more food
anytime thank you so much enjoy enjoy
such a pleasure such a treasure a
pleasure and a
treasure that's W everybody a great
guy
damn crazy that is so good so which is
better now that you've had
both just cuz I have to like think about
this when I eat e a little bit of
downside but I think this is better this
is more flavorful the other one is
easier to okay
the ease of access yeah I like to just
be able to eat as much as possible as
quick as
possible see I kind of like
the the caveman aspect and especially
it's not that bad cuz there's other
handheld foods that are like a total
nightmare to eat for example like a
turkey leg like that is always goes so
sideways yeah but that one you got a
nice clean
handle it's good God damn that's a 10
that's a 10 there it is while Gourmet
fresh and authentic zesty Middle Eastern
sauce secret Family
Recipe quality is our number one
priority it's
awesome so um big FID on the line big
FID is ready to go so here's what I want
do in the he's in the waiting room I'm
going to go to the bathroom Okay I'm
going to run there and back okay you'll
basically won't even realize that I was
gone and when we come back we're going
to have some really deep conversations
with fidus fantastic can't
wait you're not
running you're not running dude you are
slow walking I slow him down bro what
the hell I want to this
uh somebody said as a wow player
we aren't all bad love women and have a
beautiful H Tre loveing girlfriend yeah
I know I I'm I'm just teasing I'm just
teasing I played some wow a couple
months ago with that new that new thing
thing that they did oh yeah the new old
thing the um season of season of
Discovery Discovery right yeah uh so
yeah I'm right there with you
buddy I'm right there with you buddy
hope you guys had a good break we did
well I did I can't speak for everybody
Ian was sick for like the whole thing
apparently so he probably has a
different
answer although Ian you were telling me
you were playing Alan Wake while like in
a fever feverish state right how was
that yeah I had I had some nightmares it
was it was a weird time like actually
like it was blending the the gameplay
and your your dreams together so ill and
it was like raining and I had the blinds
closed it made me like very
uncomfortable
boy sounds really relaxing I'm glad you
glad you had time to relax buddy played
it in like two
weeks so you didn't finish it no yeah
bummer that is such an Ian game for
those that don't know Ian Ian likes the
weird games where you walk slowly and uh
mostly that he always says that he likes
walking simulators you put a character
in the woods I'll like the game yeah
right I'm the exact opposite I needed
juice in my brain
constant that's what I like did you guys
play that new Spider-Man I mean it's
been out for a little bit but uh no I
watched my buddy uh stream it a little
bit and it looked pretty cool but uh I
haven't I haven't tried it out I started
it it's it is really cool I didn't play
the other ones but I liked
it yeah I mean the swinging around the
city and everything looks like it would
be pretty
entertaining uh I have a baby over the
break and now she's listening with me oh
congratulations Lexi oh my God
congratulations oh my God just now that
she's listening with you like that's the
cutest thing I've ever heard that's very
cute uh just got out of the hospital
with internal bleeding oh no needed you
guys last week dude
what what first of all I'm sorry that uh
you're in the
hospital there's several things about
this message that that I'm curious about
so I just got out of the hospital with
internal bleeding that implies that you
gained the internal bleeding status in
the hospital in which case you should
probably turn around and go back all
right chill out D you little doctors
well I'm just I'm just saying and then
and then needed you guys last week dude
it it sounds like it's our fault our
fault that he's bleeding internally uh
so I I am sorry that's happening though
I'll take responsibility I'm so sorry so
sorry someone is literally bleeding
inside because of us your fault wait
what did we do it's unclear we didn't
help what the message we didn't help we
weren't we weren't here the message was
just got out of the hospital with
internal bleeding needed you guys last
week dude
so sorry you should have told us sooner
we would have come back for
you if there's anybody with internal
bleeding next time during break let us
know yeah send a send an email or
something at least we're can group up
unionize or something yeah Julia Frost
thank you for the 50 gifted wow that's
nice Julia all right all right this uh
this poor guy he's sitting in our
waiting we got to we got to let him in
yeah all right
is coming in one moment I'm so
excited big FID okay
and oh it's just like the shot are we
connected to audio yet real or is that
the shop okay now we should be connected
on audio hello are you hear me hey
FID can you hear me big FID
can can you hear me I cannot hear
you
no I see I see uh what yeah can you hear
me we can hear you fine yes oh and
I cannot hear you only so let me let me
see this is good this is just what I
wanted this is
perfect um yeah we are I I see the
levels bouncing on our uh output so how
is now can you hear me still yeah we can
hear you but yeah can you still not hear
us I'm supposed to hear you from the
live or I'm supposed to hear you from no
my headphones Zoom I don't know how to
communicate that the point to the
headphone yeah oh I apologize I you
found out guys that I'm stupid in real
life as well no no no no can you hear me
now no no I
cannot wait so the to answer me
perfectly are you are you
sure oh wait can you I
f f Do you want me to get you like a a
chalk
board oh yeah I'm I'm messaging him in
the the chat too big fit
fitus I mean this is a good first
appearance we could probably wrap it up
let's check back in next
[Applause]
[Music]
week
n clature or we don't love SE
selfawareness so yeah exact we love the
self
aware Fus how are
you I'm very good I'm very excited guys
I've been loving so hard when you guys
are making fun of me I'm enjoying it so
much so I'm I'm here for another right
in real life it would be so much fun oh
that's so nice you're that's a sweet
that's really
sweet but so you've seen kind of our
reaction to like your Japanese video and
we also reacted to your Skid Row
video I'm curious about do you think
anything went wrong in those videos or
do you think it's just that's kind of
what you you planned for it for example
like the Japan
one well the Japan one is very
interesting first of all I did the this
since the start of my YouTube channel I
was sneaking inside buses and trains and
I was traveling across every country for
free I traveled to United States for
free to India for free right for free in
what way is it
free well I was sneaking in
right cuz free implies that it's like uh
was given to you for you
know okay yes yes yes so I was doing
illegal activity you are right okay good
thank yeah so uh I was doing this videos
uh and I built my channel out of this
traveling for free videos I did this in
Europe I did this everywhere and when I
went to
Japan it was uh the first time that
people got mad at it uh so uh and the
other videos had like five million views
four million views 3 million views a of
people were watching them but yeah I
think generally there is something wrong
with this uh format of traveling for
free uh because I it started with good
intentions I don't have bad intentions I
wanted to show the kindness of people
and stuff but uh when you become let's
say a bit successful on YouTube and you
are doing for free it's like you are
taking advantage of the situation and
making money on this stuff so maybe I
don't know I can do that again but maybe
uh have get a job there and make money
and go to the next place in a way so uh
do you ever consider doing one traveling
at the fair uh market rate from here to
here what what I'm going to do a whole
trip from Paris to Moscow at the fair
price rate of
travel uh What uh what you pay for like
you pay for all the tickets
and stuff and then you're but that's not
fun that's boring okay all right fair
enough fair enough so what's the deal
you think that what's the deal with the
Japanese why do you think they care so
much well first of all I love them uh I
love everybody in this world and all
this stuff uh uh I do them out of I
don't know because I think it would be a
good video and do some good with the
video Never my intentions are to do bad
stuff but when you are doing this m mind
ET of getting views and chasing the
views and all this stuff you are going
to make a lot of mistakes I think so I
need to BU by the way I want to admit to
everyone that I am a Mr Beast copy cut
so I am a self aware of that that you
guys I don't think we care about that
we're not that we're not that productive
of
Beast what do you mean I'm I'm saying
like I don't think our fans care that
you're copying Mr Beast content I know
probably a lot of people say that to you
we're not one of them I say go I say
steal more from
him well uh the when I introduce myself
what what type of videos I making the
first thing I'm saying I'm a Mr B copy
cut so I I'm taking this uh format and
it's working it's getting a lot of views
and I'm trying to adjust how to get more
views and Make a Better Business and
make uh better videos so uh for example
they attend
when I went to skit that you said uh
that's my city too you were right there
man it's crazy you were so close to me I
was living in Los Angeles for two years
so when I was doing videos with arak uh
so oh I hate that guy is he
still your friend or did he get too big
time for
you uh no he's not still my friend but
he helped me a lot in the wait wait wait
what happened with him cuz he you know
what this guy went on stage and he
called me ugly and I and I am so pissed
off about that y so what happened
between you and this coward um
AR do you think you are the most
beautiful person in the world you are
not ugly but by the
way Fus Fus that's not this are you
defending
Iraq no I'm not defending Ira but by the
way one time you were making fun of me
in the podcast and I said in my podcast
that that I am ugly and you said no he's
not that ugly he's just a bit aggressive
and stupid something like that so you
said that I'm not ugly so you defend it
that I'm not ugly so wait is that good
or bad that I said you're not that
ugly well it's not good not bad nothing
is good how you perceive it well you
said I'm ugly and I said you're not that
ugly so it's kind of like I'm upgrading
you said said you are yeah yeah so what
happened why are you guys
friends so
um uh there
when he had I I I went with him when he
had 1 million subscribers I did some
videos to get his attention and then he
liked my personality and put me in more
and more videos but uh at some point I
got uh I was working for free for him
for one year and he was putting me in
videos I was getting Expos on my YouTube
channel I was learning a lot and at one
time when I had like 5,000 500,000
subscribers I was like I don't like I
don't want to have a
commitment to be in his Channel all the
time so I told him that I want to be in
not in all the videos I want to travel I
want to go back to my country to Europe
for a couple of months I don't want to
have a commitment and he understand so
he said that uh I want a person that
will be here for the long term if I'm
going to build him as a character and
all this stuff so we kind of separated
the way but it was uh a bit
transactional it was not like we were
friends uh okay but it ended on good
terms nobody hats anybody so I love him
and if he was not him I was not going to
be a YouTuber now so thanks to him but
you hat he did call me ugly for why do
you hate him dude he called me ugly on a
stage oh I'm being told this is actual
that's actual face I'm so sorry Ethan
that's what he said about me he said I'm
so sorry that's his actual
face that's up don't you
think uh well I thought it was pretty
funny I didn't ask you
though let me ask let I want to dig deep
in some stuff because you seem like a
deep
thinker by the way I love that you guys
are a bit conflicted about me if I'm
completely stupid or if I'm deep F and
you guys kind of like me and you kind of
get me at the same time I really love
this so I'm very excited to kind of s
well let's see we can determine
now um let's see
here what is what is
God what is god um I'm not sure like I'm
not sure what is life like I'm not sure
if I
am if everything that we see uh around
us is real because I spoke with some
scientists in the podcast that they said
that scientifically is not sure uh no is
it's proven that we cannot see 100% of
the reality we see kind of distorted the
reality so you never know what's the
actual reality so I'm not 100% sure and
I am
very stupid to understand that I'm I'm
smart enough to understand that I don't
know a lot of things about that I'm just
interested in this topics and this is uh
uh kind of my answer I don't know but my
father is a priest in Christian religion
Christian Orthodox religion so I grew up
uh in church and stuff and I still feel
a connection to God in a way but I'm not
sure if that's uh higher power if that's
uh the Universe if that's Earth I'm not
sure what it is what are your thoughts
on the technological singularity when do
you think that's going to happen and
what's the impact you believe will have
on
Humanity well uh first of all uh
Singularity and I want to make sure that
uh we mean the
same term we mean the same thing by the
way forgive me for my English guys I not
only I'm stupid I have bad English and
this combination makes a lot of mistakes
so so uh uh Singularity is something
that you don't know uh what will happen
after that like for example we can
predict five 10 years in the future but
uh The Singularity is like something
that is uncertain what will happen after
uh so uh if we uh if we advance so
rapidly that we are advancing and we
have a snowball effect that advancement
maybe until 2040 I don't know uh but by
Singularity we mean the word would be so
different that we cannot even imagine
wow so probably in 20
years
wow I'm curious to understand like what
are these topics you are trying to test
the wat or
what I'm just I I know you as a great
thinker so I just trying to pick your
brain what are your thoughts on MAR
Margo
Robbie what do you think about Margot
Robbie uh I think she's the one of the
most beautiful women really what would
you do to
her
uh
I say it I was I will say one one time I
must B oh
God
[Laughter]
and what was happening in your
fantasy just one time I think you are
asking for too much there yeah I want to
be as honest as not as not like uh
saying something things that are
not appropriate yeah she is she is
beautiful she's amazing as a bar as
everything every character that she
plays she's right so just one
time I think just one time I don't
believe
you no I'm honest I'm the most honest
person in the world you can ask me I
would be so honest with you anything I
never said lie I think you've never lied
[Music]
okay
all right well that's fidus
everybody nice to connect you seem like
a really nice guy honestly genuine nice
guy we love that what happened with you
and your girlfriend she seems so nice
have you considered getting back with
her which one the the one you did the
podcast with oh the uh
yes uh she found another person now
she's with another person so I
didn't consider though uh to get back
with K
because uh
I I we broke up for a reason so
there I don't want to go back to here oh
understood what are your thoughts on
Gypsy Rose one last
question what who what is Gypsy
Rose she's the she's the girl that like
killed her mom or something she killed
her
mom well I I if I don't know something I
try to stay out
smart I said something smad
hisory dab on that all right
that's fous everybody we look forward to
your H future
content
I it will be it's I just want to say
that I sometime I I like what you are
doing guys kind of criticizing people
and all this stuff but just make sure
you don't get to to the other line that
you you just criticize to to just make
money and like don't care about the
other people so uh because that's the my
problem with all these uh industry that
you are doing but for ex I I think with
me you didn't cross the line you were
just crial you were playful that's
nice so good job on roasting me the most
cool way possible here's one for you
[Music]
brother gentleman how was that did it
look good it was beautiful very good you
know what crazy Teddy started dabbing oh
no shut up shut up shut up and he does
it perfectly oh he's like so good
at it he
like and he learned it he watched these
guys on YouTube he's way too young I I
watch it with him it's fine but like you
know these guys lanky
box you know them big FID so they make
kids content and he he loves
them and now my one-year-old is watching
these guys he's almost two to be fair
and they love these lanky box characters
and so they taught him how to
dab yeah here they are and I'm learning
actually it's kind of interesting I'm
learning all these games that like are
popular you know there's this
whole world of of like gaming for kids
and it's a huge market like uh have you
guys heard of um ban band's
Garden this is like a this is like a
phenomenally successful game you know
band band's Garden check that
out all
right
right all right fed thank you so much
brother W my pleasure guys I love you I
love everybody that
watching all right if you need if you
need money for any trans if you need
like a train ticket or something I'll
I'll help you out
okay or a breakfast whatever you need
are you
sure you up you want to hang
around yeah I'm done you could be yeah
you could be you know you probably have
some good commentary we we gon actually
you want to learn about Gypsy Rose with
us yeah let's do it okay did you feel
bad about stealing the sleeping bag from
the homeless
person uh yes but I was so call
the I he didn't I didn't care but would
they I knew that but wouldn't they need
it if it's so cold did you dab on them
they need they didn't need it because it
was there and I was next to it and I was
watching when I was there so so it was
like 3:00 a.m. in the morning who needs
a sleeping about 3:00 a.m. in the
morning so I just took it for two hours
but yes I agree that was dude you're
Fearless best that you're you're you're
Fearless you know that like you you do
stuff that ordinary people wouldn't
do
uh yes what is that
agree
uh I don't know uh I've been I've been
in the Navy Seals uh when I was uh in my
country I finished Navy Seals school so
after that uh experience you kind of
become Fearless I guess you're special
ops yes because when you drown you in
the cold and all this stuff there
nothing nothing can scare you in life
Wow f is is special offs wow now he's
stealing complimentary breakfast so so
and when you're on Skid Row you're not
afraid for your and and that's why I'm
so good in steing stuff and getting away
with yeah not in Japan actually no I got
away with it in Japan but not really oh
no I got away it in real life but after
everyone was mad at me so I got didn't
you get you got pulled into the police
station at one point oh yeah that's
that's true because I was short for 50
cents when I collected money for the bus
right so that's true yeah um so you not
afraid of homeless people then like you
take the sleeping bag you take what you
want and you you're
trained come on and they're probably M
they probably so bad I agree with you I
agree with you yeah you agree and then
the thing is homeless people are
probably they're emaciated they don't
eat enough so you probably would
probably him up if it it came down
to it no could you defend against a
knife
attack yes 100%
really yeah I I love the homeless people
I was like when I was when I was I was
living in Hollywood and I was walking
around speaking with them I I I don't
have any problem I see them as regular
people and to be honest I I would say
something very probably radical but
isn't it this is very crazy okay crazy
idea but isn't it
uh by the way it comes down to you guys
remember when you were making fun of me
ah ah uh you see it here in real life so
uh sorry
what he was saying we made fun of his
stutter in the past oh I'm sorry I
didn't mean to do that if I did that's
not
cool no it's cool because it's funny
uh so isn't it racist to see like uh a
person uh paric and treat him different
than other people because he's paric I
think treating everyone the same right
is
the for example so let's let's say I was
going to steal a sleeping back from a
normal person I'm going to steal for a
homeless let's say this is a crazy idea
treat them equal what about equally
would you steal a sleeping bag from a
paric yeah so you would steal a sleeping
bag from a
paraplegic no it was wrong I made a
mistake and I apologize no I like where
your logic is but treat everybody the
same no matter if they're paric or if
they have limbs that's amazing I love
it that's
awesome
um let me ask you this before you go
what's your most controversial
opinion oh bro you love controversy you
want to expose me the out of me no
it's something you're comfortable with
but I you you're you're an unusual
thinker I'm curious what's your most out
there you know opinion about
something
um I feel democracy is is but democracy
is bad that is it that is a take people
it so what's go ahead what's because
yeah
uh like every four years we get to vote
we don't get we just elect out of three
candidates that have from parties and
all this stuff so it's like a joke like
nobody you nobody his straight
mind I believe will think that what we
have here as democraty is the actual
good system that will help the world so
imagine if after 50 years they will look
back I think like we look back that
people have horses and democracy will
evolve will become more I don't know for
us to vote with our phones to for us to
for I don't know more more vote more
often have more saying so you like
democracy I don't like Dem I hate
democracy as it so I just you don't like
yeah you don't like it as it is but if
we could vote on our phones that'd be
dope yes vote on our phones put opinions
and maybe they pass have active role in
democracy I'm not sure how if that's
what democracy is that's probably
something different how do you feel
about the um the uh democratization of
the
workplace well that was too many
how do you feel about um about turning
the workplace into a um into a situation
where everybody votes equally on the
outcome
well I think that's uh that's
interesting but a lot of the
times the you have lack of knowledge to
make a decision ah so that's probably a
CEO will have so much information about
the current state of there you go that
aidus is is he is arguing in favor of
capitalism well done said very well
based CEOs are the people that
need to be making the decisions and I
agree brother you disagree or no I agree
with you I'm a I'm I'm with you all the
way I don't okay I don't
you
go all right dab on
employees that was an aggressive dab
brother don't hurt yourself you ever
hurt yourself
dabbing uh no I hurt myself doing a
video ring a half marathon barefood on
the snow that's not what I asked that's
not even close to what I
asked okay but you got an answer
though all right it's fair way I put it
I guess so you've been hurt before
basically that's you turned it
into no I well you turned it you turned
have you ever hurt yourself dabbing into
have you ever been
hurt no not really you've never been
hurt okay
dabbing all right well there it is fidus
he does not like democracy as it
is do you think that voting on our
phones would pose any kind of security
issue well uh now with the with so
Advanced cyers security and
cryptocurrencies all there's no
hacking I think I think there is hacking
but probably we're you are going to come
up with a a better uh like for example
or
voting voting on Twitter I don't know
something that is
legitimize legitimized I don't know I'm
just proposing the ideas I'm not here
that's kind of fire presidential
election on Twitter that would be nuts
that would actually be so freaking nuts
oh yeah yeah but I don't think China's
hacking us or anything like that I don't
think they'd have access to
[Music]
anything well fair enough
I all right buddy Fus it's been a joy
it's been a pleasure uh thank you for
calling in thank you for being a good
sport by the way oh you know what I'm
going to let you go just cuz I know it's
like 3:00 a.m. there right you're going
to let me know because or you got bored
of me or because it's 1:00 a.m. 1 a.m.
which what time do you usually go to
bed uh I can stay awake for you for the
next two days if you want two
days you're planning a video eh no I'm
not I stay on the H podcast for 48 hours
without
sleeping do you want to hear something
funny how funny on a scale one to
10 it's pretty F I think it's nine nine
all right I'll I'm gonna judge you I'm
gonna judge you go
ahead this is the first time I'm going
to say it publicly but I'm going to run
for the elections in my country Cyprus
as a one person being in the European
Parliament out of the 700 uh people that
they get to be and and I'm curious to
see how it will go it would be for a
YouTube video but I actually want to win
my country is only 1 million population
and I'm kind of the most famous person
here in my country so I'm I'm curious to
see how it will go maybe we can the next
time we can uh but I have very low
chances like can I ask question 10% can
I ask you a question not that what you
said isn't interesting but I didn't find
funny at all well as a stupid like the
stupid YouTuber running for Parliament
all this stuff I think it's funny okay
it's never been done before though it's
little funny nobody n out of 10 I don't
think it's a nine out of 10 but it's
funny that he's going to run for office
you know what is can I point something
out how much you think I mean it was
Zero it was like it's like a three out
of 10 in fun zero it's a little funny
but it's not like it's interesting I
like the idea it's a nine it's a nine
for me it's a nine for you you laugh I
laugh weirdly he laughs weirdly yeah I I
do think it's funny that he asked for
your controversial opinion fidus and you
said that you are not a fan of democracy
and now you've just let us know that you
running an election he it's the emperor
this is how democracy ends he doesn't
like modern-day democracy I know but
like he wants Twitter I'm not just
saying you don't have to think about
that deeply but just the that adds some
humor right it's ironic that's funny and
itself right yeah he say he doesn't like
democracy but he's running an election
okay if you get that meta then it's
pretty good joke right that's like seven
out of 10
funnyp that be 10 out of
10 are you going to do that as part of
your election campaign dab on the
citizenry I think so I will I will send
you some for you could be like zinski he
had a kind of a similar rise and then
you could you could also fight the
Russians you think you'd be make a good
wartime
president no not yet
no well they say X Navy Seals you know
fidus they say nobody's ever truly
ready well some people are some people
had already ducky getting into you know
just paper oh yeah he's
okay oh people well hold on did hold on
this person said don't come for me but
why is fidus kind of dot dot dot I think
someone might have the hots for you
brother oh no the whole chat has been
saying they like so I said he's not that
ugly but chat says no no no this man is
fine piece of man meat break me off a
piece I want to this let's
see it you're you're trained seal you
know show us what you're working with oh
man this went well for the last
person that's for the ladies for the
ladies only what about gay men are they
allowed to look or no yes they are
allowed oh look but don't touch all
right all right let's see what you got
there buddy Jeff Whit watch out you
might get bumped
[Music]
oh that's that's a future President
right
there oh do balance I want to
this
looking good brother I apologize
people for my stupid n but I did it for
entertaining purposes no you looked good
man are you entertained like M saying
are you like the Gladiator is saying I
was going to say are you not entertained
did you know that you had this poll on
women it seems like the women are going
nuts for you did do do you generally
have a this appeal this magnet magnetism
for to for women do they come to
you
opposite yeah I feel that
brother I have the opposite effect I
repel do you know how hard I had to
fight to get a woman interested in me
it's tough dude
and YouTube people think helps a lot but
YouTube doesn't really help I didn't
even have YouTube at the time I was just
a dude I didn't have a
job YouTube I didn't have a damn
job yeah all right big fit we you know
what this was a great talk I appreciate
it you won us
over you did no but please guys if I do
other stuff please make fun of me don't
don't now don't become not right
you got it brother fair you got it man I
appreciate you giving us the green light
I appreciate
that okay all right get some sleep we
love you get out there and steal some
boy we're
watching I will try to improve and never
actually before I leave I did this
stealing stuff and because when you are
young you want to break the r you want
to do all this stuff but I feel that
chapter of my life that's stealing stuff
and doing all this stuff it's closed and
how old you you see 23 oh you're so okay
you're such a young man good for
you I'm old as how old do you think
I
am uh
40 just up a few years from there no I'm
third no Dan I'm 382 42 you were pretty
close I'm
38 wow
Ethan Clan ladies and
gentlemen oh that's a that's a soundbite
right
there 38 23 good for you man all right
listen FID get out there and take the
World by the B by the what are we taking
the World by the horn the horns or
something else horn the horn by the
sleeping bag take the World by the
sleeping bag and Mar
Robi have you
have you heard this one fous I don't
know if you play it Zach the
actor actress Maro Robby bro I want to
this
so that was a bit nasty I
apologize but yeah she's so pretty guys
she's so you had I mean
damn you really just went you put it all
out there she's so pretty oh it's so
funny I want to this
we really liking that sound by I
think it could be a contender
potentially oh absolutely that's a good
one all right Fus it really was nice
talking to you appreciate you calling in
thank you Fus my pleasure guys I love
you all right we'll be we'll be watching
good luck out there we wish you well be
well bye by uh future president of
Cypress wow wow that was everything I
hoped it would be you know I always I'm
always happy when they call in and win
us over like that mhm he's a good guy
he's got a great attitude he's a good
sport yeah he was self-aware very
self-aware yeah which is to his credit
obviously it's interesting he had some
interesting ideas about paraplegics and
stuff yeah yeah and like like everyone
else stuff yeah make them go down the
stairs just like everyone else yeah I'm
not racist walk down those
stairs h
well good luck to him on his campaign I
mean like he said you know Cypress is a
small island only a million people I
didn't even know it was that small
that's crazy right yeah says he's the
most famous Cy cyprin ciony cyot cyot is
that it cypron something like that um
cypr I mean wait hold on who's just in
raw numbers maybe I don't who is the
most famous living person from Cypress
there's a lot of people who move there
from Europe because they have low tax so
famous people move there but originally
from Cyprus maybe probably Contender
here I have academic and scientist
nobody cares actors nobody
cares um
artist no artist businessman it's me
it'ss historical King there's lots of
Kings on here jurist what the does
that mean famous
jurists the hell musician there's this
is a long list man mythical figures are
even on here they had to put in they
don't they put in the mythical figures
they're so desperate and here here's the
the people that are not real that are
famous in our
culture number one it says it's been
around for a while it's been around for
a while George Michaels but he's not
around anymore rip is fidus on this list
what's his name let me see if on the
list uh I'm not saying his name but I
also don't recognize any of the people
they're claiming are famous so they're
probably more either just European or
even just local locally wellknown his
name oh it is fidus yeah he's not you're
not on the list boy I found I found his
Source famous birthdays he's number one
from cyphers okay oh famous well so he's
right there you go he's right
on that's our boy I want to this
oh yeah I don't even know who these
other people are like easy dub easy dub
for big things says he's 27 did he not
just say he's 23 he did say
23 and I was shocked I was like wow much
younger than I you think he's lying
about his age yeah I don't know he's
definitely not wait why would he lie
about his AG he told me he's the most
honest person alive I didn't personally
I didn't question it but now that he
does don't you think it's more likely
that famous birthdays is wrong that does
seem more likely that does seem more
likely let me see how accurate mine is
to see all the people know my birthday
though it's like not a
secret why do you who the i' I
think I've talked about this but why the
did you choose who did
this like what is this photo and why who
who has done this to
me okay I mean yeah there's a good one
this is not the
cover 38 there it is they're they're age
for me is
exact
mhm should I read my synopsis here's
trivia he began working as a marketing
executive in Israel he and his wife hila
created a collaborative Channel called
Ethan which has more than 500,000
subscribers
true very
true originally from California he moved
to is Israel with his wife hila that's
true they were forced back to United
States but would make their way back to
Israel
again they welcomed the son
Theodore they welcome another Sun Bru
this this is very accurate
actually very accurate number two from
venturo who's more famous to me what who
the this August
Maturo who's this Punk this dude's got
me beat idiot dumb ass wait boy
meet girl meets world is that a new show
yeah it's a these Young Bucks are
coming up man I thought I was the big
Ventura Superstar I'm running for May of
Ventura
actually all right very
exciting who's number one in the whole
world in famous birthdays you know what
I
mean that's who I want to know Matt Pat
crushing it he's trending up Bob
trending up big time rest in peace 115
Bobby boy up there Taylor Swift is on
the top she's the most famous birthday
yep the full list is in the Discord
thank you yeah let's take a look here
this is important data so T Swift is
number one Charlie demilio so her star
has not
Fallen she's the number two birthday
girl Beast is
eight be is
11 look at all these famous
birthdays it doesn't even say their
birthday date doesn't say the
date shouldn't it say the
date Michael Jackson is 28 still here
let me look at the
trivia did you know that Michael Jackson
had motion sensors outside of his master
bedroom
his 1982 album thrill became the
bestselling album in history that is a
good album
boy all right famous
birthdays fidus you got some explaining
to you bro this says you're
27 and I lived with them it was one of
the most
relaxing relaxing feeling I felt ever
like there were nothing to think about
like even if I had stuff messages like
they environment they didn't give a
but I I was very happy and I'm very
grateful that you chose to come because
uh this is kind of a big thing for me
because I love this kind of video and
like the podcast and starting I was like
yeah thank you thank you so much you're
welcome thanks yeah thank you I love you
thank you for the conversation and now
we're going to spend the whole day
together without cameras bye people what
no we're not doing
that um so here is a Instagram post from
195 weeks ago why did he lie well hold
on hold on there's so many layers to
this he told me he's the most honest
person a liot listen and he straight
lied to my face wait wait wait Ethan
there's a lot going on here cuz this is
in
2020 says I'm 24 years old but it is a
cake with a 20 on it either way and this
was in 2020 which if this is accurate
then he's 23 do cyprin age
differently yeah this like the
Da Vinci Code right now we have to add
the 82 on the kids oh if you reverse it
if you he's 28 that's his real age right
I'm going to try to get him back on the
phone cuz this is like I
trusted him we have Good Rapport and now
there's a lot of we have a lot of
questions why would he type I'm 24 like
that's not a joke there's no reference
that I'm aware of that was a bit nasty I
apologize wow yeah this just I don't
know what to make of this so but then if
he is to turned 204 years ago he said
he's 23 but it it just became 2024 so if
his birthday's later in the year he
would still be 23
right I believe
him you believe him yeah I
do I believe it all right let's move on
we
uh We've dedicated quite a bit of a time
to our friend
fidus there's some other pressing
matters to get to before we get to the
Gypsy Rose situation are there for
example our friend Arab world news I
don't know y if yall remember him oh of
course he's our exclusive official H3
podcast News of the World sour
apparently his channel got um
demonetized which is a damn shame and a
tragedy however he started a new
channel and I wanted to give it a shout
out oh he didn't post anything
yet come on man
subscribe wait hold on subscribing not
available wait it says in air
subscribing not available while using
permissions h oh are you a
mod am I a mod oh maybe he made wait I
might be cuz this is our pcast Channel
I'm B yeah a wait well shout out so you
don't need to don't worry about it what
an honor I was able to subscribe there
you go so how do I what can I do if I'm
a mod M can I
edit uh well if you can don't don't I
just want to see I don't think I am a
mod cuz I I just you know
yeah and actually uh I don't think that
that is the actual podcast account that
you're logged into on there it's like a
dummy account just has that icon all
right so anyway give a shout out to Arab
world news I was hoping to watch some of
his current coverage
but well he's just getting uh back on
his feet but yeah I uh I spoked with him
uh right before the break about all of
this uh he was asking for advice and uh
it did from the from the the way that he
described it to me it did seem like
I I don't really understand why
his channel anything wrong world news
he's like the gentlest soul in the world
right so uh I I I advise him to just
appeal to YouTube and go through that
whole process but I guess they rejected
his appeal so he goes hey do you have
anyone at YouTube to help I'd be like I
don't have anyone at YouTube to help me
yeah
exactly just their biggest live streamer
probably close to probably not actually
speed is a YouTube live streamer you
probably
yeah he's pretty big yeah he's a big
deal uh okay here's one more thing that
I've been noticing over the break that I
want to talk about comedians are
starting to take themselves so
seriously it's like the unfunniest thing
in the world they were the last defense
well like it's been happening it's been
happening but like aren't comedians
supposed to be
like irreverent IR IR
reverent and like uh the whole point is
not to take yourself seriously that's
funny mhm there's very few people in the
world that should take themselves
seriously a doctor is one it's pretty
serious maybe uh what about like a what
about like a fun doctor like a Patch
Adams type situation Dr Dre well Patch
Adams died didn't
he uh the actor did to the goat dude
that's not what I meant then but Patch
Adams die as Bill or some I there was
someone died in it but what I'll say is
that in the words of Bill Gates well he
died
so it's not your
fault all right anyway the point I'm
getting to is Joe Rogan and Jimmy Carr
did was this one cleared yeah okay I
just checked again right
now you know what's fun this is one of
these movies where it was such a big
deal and everyone was talking about it
it has horrible reviews really horrible
I mean I saw it when I was a kid but I
don't uh what was the one you just
recently watched Dan GARP was that it
what didn't you just recently watch a
Robin Williams
movie uh the world according to GARP
yeah I didn't watch that recently like
at all I watch years ago this we
talked about it recently yeah look at
this 21%
brutalized I'll tell you something else
I don't know what's the deal I love this
movie What Dreams May Come Oh Dreams May
Come isol movie it's a
phenomenal movie I love it and it's just
on 52 huh even Family Guy did a bit
about no one how bad did get
reviewed Family Guy did a bit about how
bad this movie got red that is so hypers
what the
I anyway okay so here's a clip of
uh Ryan Carr or Jimmy Carr he's a
English comedian very famous actually so
a lot of you probably know who he is and
he came on Joe Rogan and here's what
they talked
about the thing I'm working on at the
moment I'm slightly jealous of the club
I'll be honest I S saw the club last
night this is quite something to do to
set up a club and to have that community
and it's great and I think that I'm I'm
working at the moment on a I don't know
whether it's a book or whether it's a I
think it might be like an online course
but a comedy course because and how to
do stand up how to write jokes how to be
a standup I think I think here's my
vision for it I think we're going
through a golden period but maybe it's
just beginning comedy's quite a new
medium anyway yeah we get yeah nobody's
comedy's nobody's been been doing com
cly someone in our generation does you
know if you think about it like as a
career I guess I I thought comedy was
alive and well there's that's not true
there's bars there's jesters
gers and stuff like yeah yeah yeah he's
just wrong Don Rickles I was trying to
like frame it in a way where it's just
it kind of makes sense but it's just
more on it but go on this isn't even the
best part Carin and and uh Richard Pryor
were John the Baptist someone's coming
through he's Jesus he's they were the
like it feels like it's it's getting
bigger and bigger my vision is it gets
taught in schools so we teach we teach
music and we teach drama and art and I
think standup comedy is an art form and
I think we need to get
less less magical thinking and more okay
let's put down a language like music you
can write it let's come up with the I
mean I I kind of I'm working on like 50
joke types but let's come up this man
with a curriculum this is the unfunniest
you could ever speak into the into
a
microphone this dude takes himself so
goddamn seriously he wants to make com
standup
comedy required
curriculum you know and then not only
that he wants to dissect it into
different joke types yeah and do a
seminar about how to be funny which I
promise you you cannot teach you cannot
teach if somebody's try trying to teach
you how to be funny they're stealing
your
money you're better off getting like a
hustler University get a better
education there I mean to like they
don't teach standup comedy in in
American schools at least uh that's true
um but there's definitely like elements
of uh yeah theater classes and stuff
like where you do either comedic plays
or you do like improv like we had improv
classes at my high school what you're
doing is really disrespectful to Comedy
as you're you're lumping it in with
performance arts right and it's actually
more it's so much more important than
way more way more important right you
know
right right right and Joe's just like
yeah we are that we are that important
with a a way of analyzing this and teach
people how to do it because what does it
give you like if your kid does standup
comedy okay well it's they have to find
their voice uh they have to look at
things in a in a from a different angle
a different perspective it's about
patent recognition these are all
transferable skills no they are not they
are not they are absolutely not I I %
disagree I mean there's like you could
probably teach somebody to be a little
bit funnier than they currently are but
you're not going to you can't go from I
don't think so I don't even think you
can you can't even like slightly improve
somebody's sense of humor no I don't cuz
he goes he goes I can teach pattern
recognition like what are you talking
about like doing IQ tests like moving
blocks around that's supposed to make me
funny to recognize patterns yeah what is
comedy homework he clearly thinks about
comedy in a very like analytical way if
he thinks like
we're going to break it down into the 50
bullet points of of what dork
what a nerd dude my comedians are sick
you do this guy they always talk about
Richard Pryor and uh George
carlington George car Carlin George
caring George carlington you know and
here's this guy being such a nerd and
such a dumbass taking himself seriously
Richard Pryor set himself on fire with a
crackpipe that's how the comedy's
done apparently he ran down the
street on fire after smoking crack and
lighting himself on fire that's comedy
that man did not take himself
seriously and he was serious though
George Carlin just had a uh well not him
he's been dead but they someone made an
AI uh special of his comedy style and
they used his voice and it was it good I
found it enjoyable yeah that's weird as
yeah um in the evening of June 9
1980 prior poured 151 proof rum all over
himself and lit himself on fire other
sources very tragic and you guys are
both laughing no he does a bit he has a
famous bit about it oh I know I I've
seen it so give me a break other sources
including the LAPD say that what burn
him that night was an explosion that
happened after free basing
cocaine how bad can you be at smoking
and crack I never heard of that but well
I mean yeah you are an authority so I've
done it once before um the way he told
the story is that he was he blew the
crack bike exploded and he said on fire
right
so shout out shout
out Jimmy car you don't know anything
bro shut up go smoke some crack you
coward and it's about finding your voice
the reason every standup is interesting
to watch is because it's individual
voices and really what's growing up
about what's school about finding your
voice finding out what you're about
finding out who you are like I don't
think it's a dumb idea to teach standup
comedy and to say well everyone should
give this a go even people that have
done I've got a couple of people that
come and see me live or whatever that
tell me oh I did like four or five gigs
10 years ago but they enjoy standup
comedy more than the average person it's
like someone who's
anyway pretty obnoxious little bit uh
there's more though there's been a whole
slew of comedians annoying me uh here's
Rogan in the same vein
saying this is
phenomenal I'll just play it you guys
can react to it it's short wait why
didn't it show a
video you know it did that to me
yesterday uh it it ended up showing up
but I had to refresh it okay here we go
here we go yeah I just refreshed all
right Joey drop some knowledge on me
yeah we say you know in the comedy world
we say we're the last line of defense
because this is where where the woke
meets the wall the woke meets the wall
with standup comedy yeah the last
line of defense Jill Rogan against W
last line of Def specifically yeah we
say there's where woke meets the wall if
you think about it he is the most his
work is more important than pretty much
anything yeah yeah yeah like you know
they were the last line of defense
it's the last line of defense yeah
so what if we didn't have comedians I
think we'd probably be Nazi Germany
probably would have lost to the Nazis
the Nazis were very woke by the
way they were they were so why because
anti-Semitism is now a woke thing I
don't know it's just because they always
say it's like the woke the woke Nazis
like that's what they they claim they're
defending against so woke Nazis yeah but
I mean dude come on you guys sit in a
room and goof around like shut the
up it's so
obnoxious you know maybe you inspire
some people maybe you say something
that's interesting and unique you're not
the last line of defense stop taking
yourself that seriously they were the
last line of defense no you're not Joe
they were the last line of defense
no the last line of
defense
yeah we Joe Rogan who's like I think
vaccines cause
autism we're the last line of defense
say you know in the comedy world we say
we're the last line of defense shut up
uh and then the next one this one's
actually just
really
um really infuriating this guy Andrew
Schultz recently though he's popular you
guys probably all know him he has a
podcast called flagrant 2 I don't know
what happened to flagrant one
but apparently just skipped over
it um they had this dude academics on
who is a DJ Drake Drake my top five is
Drake Drake Drake he's the Drake guy so
anyway I've been watching a lot about
him this guy sucks so bad but anyway
here watch this clip and I guarantee
you're all going to hate him afterwards
recently though the driver came up which
by the way here's the thing if we're
going to think about this tonight you
have three people who go to a party it's
Kylie J's party they're all intoxicated
Apparently one of them was one of them
is about to be passed out try one of
these what is this that's
we he's telling a story and he just flat
out Jesus just ends his story to do this
it's a Zen it's nicotine oh hell no
you're going to be hooked I'm good I'm
good it's not about a hook you won't get
hooked hell no uhuh I'm good it's it's
like a dip just try it will you just try
it I got addictive personality for real
for real this is not going to make you
add an addtive person like I have a
really addictive like you see whatever
you're doing right there you're going to
see me like with a mouth full of acorns
my you're not doing this
you're not about to go get me like like
like no no we're not do no I can't do it
brother you can literally take it out a
second afterwards you're not you're
going to feel H try one no no I can't do
it brother I can't do it just try the
White Boy for one why you so we Dr
to see the whole we finished a whole no
no I get it I get it what is this this
dude is doing like the Denzel like are
you going to smoke this crack or not
it's so juven bot is that a
fifth like a not it's more here yo
Andrew I can't do it that's so funny I
am like I'm an addict one thing I've
realized how many fluid oun is it we can
do the math why don't you one no no no
because I'm going to be addicted you're
not going to be addicted it's such a
stupid thing to
think also you're probably an alcoholic
anyway so what you
consider hold on dude that I don't know
that pissed me off like the it's
just gives me flashbacks to being peer
pressured to
like when you're like in Middle School
no dude just just take one Zin are even
that good anyway just take one I'll try
one is that what who's offering him yeah
try it just take it I will try it try it
now I'm with the boys I'm cool like the
boys you so easy to peer
pressure dude bro I am that's the
up thing I got talked into doing so many
things I didn't want to do that's why I
feel bad watching him cuz he's really I
see he's he's he's Drawing the Line
thanks what do I do with it so you put
it in the upper deckie right here upper
upper Dey get a little Zimbabwe action
so you swallow right what language are
you speaking do you spit or swallow yeah
yeah swallow baby never spit
cheers my
dude yeah that gives me flashbacks to
high school too being like one of the
only Arab kids there being pressured to
drink didn't want to drink even the
girls would join in they would they
would say wild too just try it who
cares about your
religion did he uh I guess did uh did he
ever give in no no he stood his ground
yeah well good for him he's a grown ass
man yeah I know but I don't know the guy
he's on that guy show and he's yelling
at him I don't know if eventually be
like just full and be like fine it
gu am I am I overreacting I I hate that
I just saw that I was like especially if
you if you had that happen to you a lot
as a kid I was always like you know cuz
that definitely happens and I was always
able to just be like no I'm not doing
that I don't care but
like I've seen other people getting
pressured into things they don't want to
do by the way I've done snooze you guys
this I'm not doing a snooze uh virginity
thing here also I think this is lighter
than snooze this is some well there's no
tobacco in this there's no tobacco so
weird there's nicotine in it yes there's
six milligrams of nicotine okay six
grams milligrams that's a blot like the
gum I chew is two yeah yeah so they
offer these in three and six I RI
through I'm not going to say why but
this has helped me well hold on you
don't smoke anymore right no I haven't
had a cigarette dude
you're and that rules that's like
the best investment ever man if it gets
you stop smoking hell yeah problem is
I'm ripping through about a can of this
a day is it expensive uh online for a
roll which is five I think is like 20
bucks so so it's similar to cigarettes
yeah so it's
not 20 bucks a day e little Zimbabwe but
yeah that's how much smokers spend on
that yeah yeah all right what do you
think um I don't really
another I need I need one for the other
side of my lip two upper deckies that's
that's hardcore show I mean I don't feel
anything yet just just getting started
this is some compared to
snooze snooze I'm telling you when I
first tried snooze my ears were shooting
out I've never felt anything like that
in my life most people would try first
time and pass out it's so strong it's so
up there's one snooze brand like
the normal snooze like the general
snooze is like 10 Mill I think of
nicotine there's one called Siberia
that's like 50 that like knocks you
sounds like it sounds like a hell dude
so how long does it take to absorb the
um starts immediately you say six or
eight this is six milligrams so how long
you think I until I get it all that um
what like it starts hitting you well how
long do you keep it in your mouth uh
about an hour 45 minutes okay yeah it's
a slow release yeah it should probably
already hit you yeah you should be I
mean I chew nicotine gum like all the
time that's true if you were used to it
you w nicotine doesn't really affect me
that much although I'm feeling it a
little bit do you feel it Zach um I I do
um the morning one really that's a good
one the coffee H um do you feel the burn
at all just a slight tingle yeah that's
that's good that's feel good love the
tingle yeah holy I might be I
actually might be addicted to these I
might be wanting to buy these I'll get
I'll bring I'll bring one for you but
these you apparently you guys say love
says this does not cause
cancer um snoo I think well I've read
studies I'm not saying this one doesn't
have nicotine so that's different yeah
you s shouldn't cause cancer in mouth
cancer this one doesn't have tobacco I
mean tobacco I think not having tobacco
is probably a very good thing from what
I've read tobacco doesn't cause mouth
cancer but I don't know well it's all
the car and all the in it the way
it's processed from what I've
looked at snoo is cured tobacco whereas
like dip and chew is not cured which is
why you have to spit it
out
so snooze It Up Wait people are saying
coffee flavor there's different flavors
all different flavors I thought they
made that illegal Zach gave me coffee
flavored one once right Zack that's what
it was coffee yeah well in the state of
California they only have the unflavored
ones if you get them online oh you gave
me some online that's the beauty of
uh America baby go next
door all right let's move on so we've
talked about that we talked about
this this Austin MC broom story is good
I'm gonna tit this really fast you guys
know I love Austin MC Brom Ace family
he's moving on to his new scam and it's
so damn funny uh this this lady who I
guess is a uh of model mhm posted this
DM she got from him didn't this guy have
his house foreclosed on she said yes he
goes my bad for the random DM are you
signed to an
agency whoa dude how nuts is that that's
pretty out there that is
nuts oh damn he's trying to get into
like the Andrew Tate
game he's trying to become a pimp mhm
yep M
hand is it vertical it's a new vertical
he's tried everything else you know so
watch out ladies Austin is in the DMS
protect yourself oh her response is good
she's a uh right on the nose she says no
I think agencies are predatory scams run
by corny men who think they can involve
themselves in women's Business yeah you
don't need that she knows exactly
what's
up have a good night have a good night
um God damn there's so much I want to
get to the lebrand family these
Christian vloggers you guys probably
know who they are they have so many kids
and they're having another kid and this
is the photo they posted like oh my
[Music]
God stop
damn they for sure had this baby for
Content like there's no question about
it oh yeah like the minute they found
out they brought all the kids out he did
this pose you know how long it took to
like do this pose hold them up perfectly
and then to have all the kids looking at
the camera and probably every time they
did it he had to go walk around to the
tripod the little tripod on the floor
look through the photos and decide if
they were good or not probably it took a
long time maybe even an hour to get this
photo right with all those young
kids yeah having them all look at the
camera that must have took a lot of time
oh you see the the younger brother's
he's it looks like he's holding his
younger sister's head
because she she wouldn't look which I
understand it's you know you can't
really tell a a young baby to to do that
type of thing so
um hopefully this kid's on salary I hope
he's getting
paid so congratulations to the lebrand
family that is a Content baby right
there my friends they actually naming
him content
interesting weird they're naming him
December Revenue it's actually really
interesting thanks thank
you have you guys seen this um Ariana's
out with SpongeBob her new significant
other I love him he's such a
interesting
dude that's what I'll say
interesting he's really
interesting but okay so here they
are I know this photo's gone around so I
don't know how many of you have seen it
but I don't think this is
photoshopped which is absolutely bananas
but here's her
brother interesting and here is
SpongeBob no that's real it's real oh
that's weird it's it's uncanny it's
absolutely
unreal like what the
hell those noses are like identical holy
the the smile mhm the
creases the eyes painted
boys painted glossy
glossy ah I was like this has to be
edited I thought it might be oh here's
another one let's
see I haven't seen this one before oh
this one's worse you think so yeah kind
of
D whoa I
mean it's really it's really interesting
how do you find two people that look so
similar you know it's interesting it is
interesting bro I want to this
that's what SpongeBob
said as he left his family a newborn
baby mhm there's no way they last right
they better they I mean there's a lot of
pressure on her yeah but I I think
there's no there's no way and then he's
just going to be the Biggest Loser of
all time yeah he's going to really
reflect over the past couple years if
they break up and look dude she has a
very specific type of man obviously
you're not going to date up like this
again mhm you know what I mean once
you're back on the free market you are
not going to be pulling damn they ruined
that baby's life for nothing then that's
what what I'm saying that baby's never
going to trust
anyone thank you next yeah get that
thing in therapy
now oh
God interesting very
interesting what do we do about
it ow it's
interesting
um this David do T is kind of
interesting I'll do this this is the
last thing I promise the David thing's a
little long we could do gpsy Friday it's
no no no we're doing it today we're
doing it yeah um is all right let's just
let's just about just jump right into it
all all right let's do it let's do the
Gypsy Rose PowerPoint this is Gypsy Rose
BL
Blanchard
Blanchard an apologies if you're Gypsy
Rose simp we are we have decided to not
leave her
alone uh in a in the prover verbial
sense that we're talking about her yeah
in the sense that we're telling her
story The Way She Wants people tell yeah
I'm kidding please leave me alone don't
clip that no don't clip that Ethan says
he will not leave Gypsy Rose alone all
right go ahead uh Olivia okay um yeah
Gypsy Rose
so great next line in order to have a
discourse about what's happening right
now all of these articles are obviously
flooding
our timelines our everything we must
have a discourse about how we got here
so next
slide one
more they're in a private plane together
yeah you they they got benefits from um
okay from how sick uh gpy was sweet
seemed to be um so Gypsy Rose Blanchard
was born in 1991 to her mother DD
Blanchard DD um with that who's ready
they uh yep Louisiana if you go to the
next one um gypsy is a victim of munchow
and byox um as soon as she was born her
mom claimed that she had sleep apnea and
then going off from there she later di
diagnosed her daughter with leukemia
muscular distrophy she said she required
a wheelchair a feeding tube and she had
a list she had a list of these problems
that just went on forever which included
also seizures asthma hearing and visual
impairment so she was actually doing
chemo and stuff um she was getting
treatments but she was shaving gypsy's
head to make it seem like she was
receiving treatments so if you go to the
I just think it's it's interesting
because we talk about how hard it is to
get medical tests when you're afraid
you're sick but Gypsy Rose has got like
she's fine and she's plugged in
man well at least at least we know she's
okay yes we did all the tests yeah we
did all the tests she's healthy mhm you
know what I mean so Gypsy wasn't
actually unwell her mother had been
lying about her symptoms um experts
obviously have nailed it down as Munch
house and bioxy D which is what which is
here I have it written Behavior stem
from mental disorder Munch Housen
syndrome by proxy DD wanted to be a
caretaker she feied and induced illness
in her daughter so it's when you
basically
um use someone usually it's kids M and
usually it's just saying they're sick
all the time so that she can get
attention and sympathy and all this yeah
need to be needed through her daughter
right interesting devastating and the
daughter I'm assuming thought she was
sick with all these things yes
yeah so um do do d d to DD's
actions Jesus Christ um gypsy she
had like
an insane amount of medications that she
was being fed with um that she was being
fed by fed with by her mother yeah wow
what kind of medicine um she there's a
photo of her it was so many there's a
photo of her medicine cabinet I can send
to you like how serious of meds are we
talking about like very serious
medicines holy that's bananas let
me send this to you that's some Twisted
ass yeah so how did the mom get the
medicine so they would go to a bunch of
different doctors and she had nurses
training and so she would be able to
accurately describe their symptoms and
like as more info has come out Gypsy has
said that like when they when she was
able to advocate for herself she would
hold gypsy's hand in the doctor's office
so if Gypsy ever said anything wrong she
would like squeeze her hand and there
was one specific Doctor Who even said in
their notes like I think this might be
Munch house and byox and she would just
pick up and leave and go to a new doctor
interesting also they were they were hit
by Katrina so that was also like lucky
for them that they lost doctor's records
oh so this was documented but it kind of
got refreshed after the the
flooding here picture so Gypsy was
gradually uh understanding that she
wasn't actually sick as Gypsy got older
she was like aware of the fact that she
could get up out of her wheelchair and
like like that but as she was
growing up she was just told you're sick
you're sick you're sick and of course
you would believe it as a child no was
your mom yeah here
oh this was did Brian kavana buy
this ohav a force so um she W so she
wasn't even sick and she went through
multiple surgeries including she had
procedures on her eyes she had a removal
of her salivary glands and G yeah and
gypsy's teeth all rotted and a lot of
people speculate it's because of all of
the medication she was taking and in the
act it showed a scene where Dee pulled
out all of gypsy's teeth
she pulled back she pulled her teeth out
because they rotted she pulled them out
yeah that that's not just from not
brushing kind of thing medicine makes
your teeth fall out yeah a lot of
medicine does that what M what medicine
makes your teeth fall out I don't know
I've heard of it a bunch of times what
kind of medicine does that I'm just
curious so medications can cause gum
problems such as inflammation bleeding
or
ulcers um yeah leading to gum disease
what kind of what kind of medicine like
what class of
medicine someone said the salivary
salivary glands being removed would rot
her teeth
out
man this is one twisted
lady all right so Ryan Kavanaugh enters
the picture yes so a gift from Habitat
for Humanity this was in 2008 uh Gypsy
and Dee they moved from Missouri uh or
no they moved from Louisiana to Missouri
because of Katrina um Habitat for
Humanity built them a house um it was
painted pink it had a wheelchair ramp
for Gypsy there was this like famous
photo op of all of the builders outside
the house with them um yeah they they
also receed benefits that included like
charity sponsored Disney trips and stuff
like that too so she was always on the
lookout for like the the uh charity
organizations so how did they get picked
to get a house from Habitat for Humanity
how does that work
that I actually don't know I know that
they claim to have lost their house in
Katrina and they had received help but
okay so generous uh wholesome people
yeah so gypsy's first attempt at running
away she was actually 19 years old yeah
you can watch it if you want
to first time I ran away from home I had
met a
friend we both went to the
sci-fi fantasy convention called Vision
con I had told him
vaguely about what was going on at home
he told me you know um you just pack
your stuff and um you can come live with
me in Arkansas and they said
[Music]
okay I snuck out got a ride from a
stranger and went over his place and
then within like 4 hours my mom found me
at his place because we had mutual
friends in common so she was starting to
call the cops on him and she took me
back home and smashed my computer with a
hammer smashed my cell phone with a
hammer and said if you ever try to do
that again I'm going smash your fingers
with a
hammer it was a rough year I called that
the bad
times so her life at home sounds like
her mom was not just crazy crazy I don't
like that word not just um absolutely
batshit psychotically insane right I'm
kidding uh but also abusive like and
very mean incredibly yeah so um when she
tried to run away with that guy who she
met at the convention after she found
Gypsy she chained her to her bed for two
weeks oh my God yeah that sound like
rose that's horrible yeah what's her
name the a passenger oh Frank Ruby
Frankie yeah um yeah and she was 19 at
the time Gypsy was but de would lie to
her about her age and she convinced even
the man too that she was underage de so
what what did how old did she think she
was well so as Gypsy got older that's
when Dee would like start making her
seem younger than she was so it would it
would like change I don't know how old
she told the guy that she actually was
but she said you cannot run away with
this girl she's
underage when she was 19 wow okay
mhm so here who's this honk okay so this
is Nicholas goed John goated goated John
um no he's actually a horrible guy he
met Gypsy online on a Christian dating
site which is after she got a hold of a
computer again she made actually five
secret Facebook accounts because Dee
would be on her so intensely just
monitoring everything but she wasn't she
didn't catch this where um she started
talking to Nicholas gadon they had an
online relationship they started to
explore his various sexual Kinks um in
some online photos she would like dress
in costume based on he self-described
had different personalities so he had
her create like pairing sexual
personalities to match his that's so
interesting growing up with a mom who's
so mentally ill Pro made probably made
this guy somewhat palatable like anyone
else would be like that this guy's the
something's not right but she's probably
like yeah this is normal yeah she's
used to all this
stuff so these are all photos she took
for him like cosplaying and stuff yeah
okay so this is their first time meeting
is they they had been discussing talking
online how they were going to finally
meet each other and they decided that
they were going to both see Cinderella
the liveaction one that came out Gypsy
went with her mother and Nicholas went
by himself there were barely any people
in the movie theater Gypsy said and Dee
they assumed that they would just meet
there and then like Dei would love him
and everything would be okay that's not
what happened obviously she was like
who's this adult man Seeing Cinderella
by himself this weird so she didn't like
him at all gypsy that made her upset and
then um they met up she's not wrong
agree Dee was right about one thing um
stay away from Nicholas um but during he
met them there yes and they sat together
or apart no they didn't sit together but
they met up during the movie and they
had sex in the bathroom holy I want
to this Jesus not now crazy
now is not the time we're trying to be
we're trying to we're trying to we hung
up on seriousness we got to hang up on
him so they they had sex in the bathroom
MH wow and mom didn't notice mama was
watching Cinderella good movie
captivating great film clearly Lily
James
so um if you're interested there's a
YouTube video of like every text that
they sent weeks leading up to the murder
um but basically through their texting
and everything she told him about her
mom and the fact that she could walk and
she ended up saying like will you
protect me from anybody he said yes she
said my mother and he said yes and
that's how the plan came to be so her it
was her idea he had the like the
homicidal ideations she wanted to get
away that's okay so but she says well
you protect me against my mom she claims
she didn't mean kill well what did she
mean by that I think she meant any way
possible and I think she in interviews
she regrets the choice and she knows
that she was liable in
it uh I'm these texts are like I put it
on times 2 speed it's not even
it's weird it's not changing
okay so they're texting they're
planning yes we're going to kill mom
yeah so
um the murder happens
I what happened
was he went into the house she let him
in she went and hid in the bathroom she
was in fetal position she was covering
her ears and he stabbed Dei to death and
then after the murder happened um gypsy
went on her mother's Facebook and she
claims it's because she wanted people to
find the body but she posted that
is
dead that's really like that's a poor
criminal ship I feel like
yeah yeah like in terms of committing
murder I would recommend probably not to
post to the dead person's right in uh
Facebook especially while you're on the
crime scene agree they made a few other
errors for example they mailed yeah they
mailed themselves the knife the bloody
knife they nailed it to Nicholas's house
yes why not carry it yeah right they
just thought it'd be easier of it yeah
and they kept all their bloody
clothes they they didn't really think
too much about it but we'll get to it
are so is there more details about how
this all came out about how the murder
came out yeah I'm just like so they're
planning
it and then they come to the house mhm
is the plan to stab her yes okay Gypsy
stole a a knife from
Walmart nice yeah okay and so where is
she where is she hiding in the house in
the bathroom and how close is the
bathroom to the bedroom she said that
she could hear her
mom okay well that's pretty
disturbing yeah and uh I have a a clip
of her recounting it if you want to
watch it I do yeah yeah let me grab
it absolutely I do and so her her her
boyfriend who let's be honest is very
committed to her mhm if you go to he's
he's a committed dude it's on the you
got to respect that about him stand up
he has a a multiple personalities one of
them is like his evil side MH and so
when they when they would like chat
online um it would be his evil side that
she was talking to who was the nice side
do we ever did you ever meet him yeah
she talked to both but like when they
would like the BDSM stuff she also Al
had like a alter ego too mhm okay yeah
like all those photos of her in the wigs
and stuff wasn't he like didn't describ
himself as like a vampire something like
that I think so yeah but he also has a a
criminal past he was um arrested for
watching can you say that porn can you
yeah you can say that okay for watching
porn at a McDonald's for nine hours nine
hours hours took 9 hours to get rid of
him jerking it for 9 hours us to watch
wait hold on how do you jerk off in
public for 9 hours and not get stopped
sooner right how they time that it's a
hell of a tug well maybe they caught him
near the end and then they went back and
look at the security footage and
realized he had been there for nine
hours so this dude is
not he's not okay he's bad new do you
think he would have killed he would have
been a murderer if even without the
Gypsy Rose connection I mean obviously I
don't I don't know a lot but I think
that he had certainly homicidal
tendencies
okay sounds like probably he had a
record didn't he before this yeah we
just said that he had caught
masturbating for nine hours in
McDonald's oh okay I I thought that
besides that I think you would get a
record for that right that is yeah
that's depends on McDonald's it's
impressive depends on where and which
McDonald's right so is there I'm heard
that there
was something he wanted to do with the
corpse is that something you're going to
touch on here
um I can talk about it I I didn't put it
in but he told Gypsy that he wanted to
sexually violate the dead
body and Gypsy told him no she put her
foot down she said the line do that to
me instead and that's what took place
after the murder so they had sex yes and
Gypsy says that it was not
consensual Jesus perfect perfect perfect
romance horrible it's a real Cinderella
Story right if you go to the second post
or the second post murder Slide the link
in there is her recounting the
murder uh so I heard he's autistic Lena
you know a lot about this Lena I do nice
feel free to supplement okay so he would
have been a fan of the show then I
probably yeah 50% chance yeah 50/50
and Gypsy also has stated since that she
was at the time um addicted to a little
bit so she was on painkillers oh wow
okay so let's go um you had to clean up
after your mother's murder you did that
voluntarily correct yes he didn't make
you no what were you doing while your
mother was being killed I was was
sitting in the bathroom on the bathroom
floor with my hands covering my
ears and how did you know when it was
over there was a code that we settled on
to
use did you set on this code together
yes what was the code I believe it
was three KN and two scratches on the
door why did you need a
code to let we know when to come out of
the bathroom did you have any concerns
about what might happen yes what
concerns did you
have I was afraid that my mother would
end up hurting
him oh my God now her mom was a fighter
she thought she her mom might
win
damn this knife why did you buy the
knife at Walmart I did not not buy it I
stole it I apologize I apologize sorry I
appreciate her
honesty right she being honest yeah do
we like that yes that's a dub right
probably good she's under oath
so she has she doesn't care about Oath
well I
mean
oath Ryan Kavanaugh was under oath when
he said that what was it he said under
oath I don't know remember uh yeah
that's he said something so he said
something under oath yeah maybe listen
to his podcast failure he may talk is it
out yet I'll probably go I think the
first guest was actually uh someone
called Jake
dittle I'm sorry I I don't see that it's
out Cav Cav is gonna like give Jake an
exclusive I tried to find it in the top
the top result when you Google it is our
website our our article about it yes
well he didn't even put out his episode
yet failure Ryan uh he still got he
failed to launch his podcast I mean it's
on brand so the first two are our
website actually that's good yeah it's
not out yet there's only the four
teasers drop it Ryan come on Ryan don't
tease me maybe he'll change the name the
fourth one is our
subreddit so we're occupying the top
three three of the top five nice it's
helpful information so it makes sense
it's not loading when I click it um also
it's not loading the oh that's
interesting oh I think I know why okay
yeah we a Web Master on I'll address
that yeah thank you glad we looked that
up yeah thank
goodness you get how about that um I he
asked me to and what was what was your
understanding was going to happen to
that knife with that night he was going
to use it to kill my mother and you knew
that when you went and sto it correct
yes now there's been some discussion of
some of these fantasies you had these
were all fantasies that the two of you
had correct yes sir collectively yes sir
uh you guys did this with some
regularity correct yes what and you
willingly agreed to make these videos
wait he he's referring to what he says
you guys did this
regularly these fantasies you
said yes and you also yourself wrote
some letters some stories all set am I
correct yes wrote for
yes and this uh reference to this
agreement that you're going to be Master
Slave that was something you guys did
together I'm going to this whole line of
questioning has been leading sustain D
it I'm it's I'm interested brother or
overruled is overruled the one that
overruled would be a rejection yeah
sustained I think means they keep
going uh oh right yeah yes sustained
means keep going sustained we love
sustained sustain your
honor oh look what you've done God damn
it YouTube and this is the defendants
with rules are very clear on that it is
it is our witness judge I'll be glad to
rephrase the question thank you so okay
uh who's whose idea was it to have this
Master Slave thing it was Nick's and did
you go along with it willingly yes did
you have a problem with
it I didn't particularly like it but I
went along with it now you talked a
little bit about this uh situation at uh
the Cinderella movie and I think you
testified on I think I got the part that
you wanted me to hear
yeah interesting so I bet this whole
thing is a good
Liston you know yeah there's a lot of
footage so what is this home so um this
video sadly I can't play cuz the only
versions I could find got claimed but um
they did like a very short Vlog in the
motel after the murders where they're
just like very giggly and they're
talking to each other
and um after that they went back to his
home in Wisconsin and they were found by
police and it was immediately yeah and
it was easy for them to arrest them
because they had the murder weapon and
the close awesome was like a YouTube
Vlog mean she was holding the camera and
she's like hi honey I'm filming you
you're eating a
brownie what up Invaders Chris here okay
smack that like button um so needs some
chapstick yeah he need some
nipple cream this these prisons are
inhumane man he needs some nipple cream
Gypsy pleaded guilty to second degree
murder and she was sentenced to 10 years
in prison she ended up serving eight and
Nicholas was was sentenced to life and
he's still serving us what's the deal
with wanting to have
quietus with the
body that's personally I don't the deal
like where did that that's that's like
not a normal yeah necropia is normal by
comparison uh yeah I think I think I'm
starting to suspect there's something
wrong with do you have any details about
like deal with that what do you mean by
what's the deal I don't know like this
guy is bananas like I wanted to
know a little bit more about him I guess
okay like where where that came from
that he's into necrophilia well like how
did she so she said no do it to me but
then like
did she ask any followup questions there
there are uh sounds like you're Kink
shaming e it's it's not a new thing
though I mean there other killers in the
past have done the same yeah I mean I
think you know it's part of the the sort
of zero killer it's normal for those two
things to get paired up yeah well noral
as far as it's normal at all I guess but
like think it it happens Ed keer from
Santa Cruz he did that after killing his
mom
um and then he severed her head and then
had sex with her head what's even
crazier what's crazier is he's the next
most famous person on famous birthdays
like
Kepler next to you wait you're from
Santa Cruz right yeah okay just want to
make sure my joke my no I'm not from
Santa Cruz I wasn't born there this is
what I'm sending you right now is a
video of his interview with police where
they ask him about that specifically
good that's what I
want that's a link okay
tell me more about you Nick you're so
interesting murder
porn did Gypsy ever come out and see her
mom uh I wouldn't let her you wouldn't
let her go in there and see her I didn't
want her to be traumatized okay um
thoughtful you's thoughtful kind he does
I think he cares
for
um did you have sex with D no you didn't
stick your penis anywhere on her nope
are you sure yep positive I'm 100%
positive okay uh did you stick your
penis in her mouth nope okay did your
penis touch anywhere on de's body nope
okay did your mouth touch anywhere on
de's body my mouth no okay you didn't
kiss her no liquor or anything like that
no okay um did did Gypsy come in and do
anything like that with her mom no touch
her mom's privates no she wouldn't do
that I know she wouldn't okay
um all right what do you think about
people that have sex with dead
bodies it's qu disturbing honestly okay
that's just that would bother you yeah
okay I don't like necrophilia okay oh is
that an actual just wait he's oh oh he's
just he's I believe him at this point
he's very credible I think what does
that mean necrophilia necrophilia
actually means they have sex with a dad
okay have you ever ever known anybody to
do that no I only know the word because
uh I tend to look up words that seem to
be popular in today's culture dude you
just got caught necrophilia is not in
the trending words of 2022 or whatever
that's true that is not top of the list
you're right the explanation is the
problem there because it's like I mean
it's not unusual to know what
necrophilia is but his answer makes it
seem like that dude is definitely
necropia yeah
exactly okay yeah
okay all right so um you you stabbed D
in the bed and gypsy's in the bathroom
and so what happens after you're done
stabbing d i uh knocked the door and I
also scratch twice to let her know that
was me instead of from oh so is that a
code you guys came up with okay so what
was the code again it was three knocks
and then two scratches okay three knocks
two scratches and then that was so that
way she would know in the bathroom it
that was so Gypsy would know that it was
you and not her mom yep okay and did you
guys plan that out
before uh we like I said we went back
and forth between more than one idea but
that would end up being the one that we
stick with okay okay um
so um after that happens after you do
the three knocks and the two scratches
do she open the door uh not right away
okay what happens she wanted to save her
private part
what
what he's
not I don't know if he's being honest
that's like
a okay okay that actually makes more
sense
than than that what he's
saying okay and her legs okay she wanted
to shave her private part in her legs
yes for me okay um yeah has she ever
done that before or is this something
new or um uh usually her mom does not
let her shave her legs okay so her mom
doesn't let her shave her legs does her
mom let her shave her private her uh her
mom never seemed to care about that
before okay so yeah so how did you know
she wanted to do that for you um because
uh she uh well she did it okay that's
how so does she Gypsy says this didn't
happen gpsy says that the sex that they
had was not consensual
right what did you do while she's
shaving her legs and stuff I waited for
her okay and then she gets out of the
bathroom it's her leg shaved and
everything's shaved and then what
happened and then uh he also like wanted
her to have pink nail polish on by the
time the murder was over it was just
like so she was doing weird stuff in the
bathroom she's painting her nails or she
had them painted for post murder he just
told her he wanted her nails pink this
is some Twisted ass crazy dude this
is nutty
man I know Stranger Than Fiction you
couldn't even dream of this
we uh set to clean up the the
ground and everything around okay clean
up what do you clean in the house uh yes
you're like vacuuming and dusting and
stuff like that uh cleaning up such as
anything that has memories of her that's
actually what we were doing I don't
understand I'm
sorry like anything that had uh uh does
he get to the the necrofilia oh no that
was her questioning him about it yeah
okay
wow horrendous would you want to grab a
beer with him or
no boys probably
pass that question about like the
president you
know Dr beer he's the kind of guy you
want to grab a beer want go get a beer
with you like
beer with the bar so the story which is
incredible got the attention of
many mommy how do I watch everything how
did I never see this mommy dead and
dearest that's got to be good right this
is like a docu
series mommy dead and dearest is a docu
series and it's actually what now
husband watched and is what forced or
like made him want to write a letter to
her in
prison right yeah um I've got to watch
this yeah so their story was dramatized
in the Hulu show the ACT which starred
Joey King now she had to get paid for
this right what Gypsy yeah it's her
story it's her likeness she should I
don't know about Mommy dead and Deus but
she did say the Act she didn't get paid
for good how
oh did not no she that's crazy she needs
to lawyer up cuz that does not make any
sense but they paid her for mommy dead
and Dearest I'm not sure about that one
she this one I wouldn't expect her to
get paid for cuz it's like a documentary
but this one's a damn TV show
monetized H that seems listen I know
she's a murderer and all this stuff but
what H what what Hulu did is not right
yeah Joey King speaks about it too she
says that they never let her go see
Gypsy in prison because she kind of
wanted to get to know her better um so
she can uh play the role and they never
let her and now looking back after Gypsy
spoke about it and said she didn't get
paid um Joey was saying like she she
kind of gets it now maybe that's why
they didn't want her seeing her I hope
she's luring up huh same you know what
Gypsy
needs HS of money and freedom you know
Gypsy wants Millie Bobby Brown to play
her oh yeah I saw that from stranger
play her in what if there's an
autobiography about her life she said
she wants Millie Bobby Brown to play uh
play her when we already got the
documentary and the series many so I'm
wondering maybe we didn't like we didn't
like saturated in the market think we're
good I think we're
good okay all right so and now we have
AR someone say you can't profit off it
when you're guilty that I don't think
that's true isn't that like related to
the OJ I mean I look into it now but
about OJ book how he wasn't allowed to
profit off the book off a crime I forget
what it is let me look into it okay the
law is you can't profit from your crimes
okay so only Hulu can you know what I
mean okay that's interesting
then then they did a heist on her I mean
that's that's nuts see that seems weird
though because the show is not just
about the murder it's her whole life
like story right
oh that feels like that's the scope of
that is more expansive than the thing
that she's guilty not everything in that
show she did was illegal right so that
seems
odd something called Son of Sam laws
prohibit criminals from profiting from
writings or shows about their crimes
however courts have frequently struck
down these laws on First Amendment
grounds yeah seems I think she got a
compelling case yeah we got to get P&P
in the M we got to get him on this let's
go I'm I'm sure I'm not the first person
to think about that I'm not client he
was in McDonald's for 9
hours my wonderful client was fully
exposed masturbating in McDonald's for n
hours there was families women children
you name
it well I'm happy to say that my client
was charged for uh a sex crime indecent
exposure to a silly Willie which is a
momer in the state of uh California the
police did not do their due process
there was no Sean in the
McDonald's the cops did a horrible job
cleaning up the
situation there was semen found on the
floor but they could not prove that it
was his because there was other seen
mixed in with
it pmp's got
it okay so what is this she's on
Instagram she's living life so that's
the end of the Case Case please watch
her lifetime docu series if you want to
know more so much information now our
girl is free this is her first Instagram
selfie she posted first selfie of
Freedom do she have a lot of followers
has 6.5 million likes yeah let's see how
many she has now followers oh my God how
I guess because of the shows that's why
people were like so primed for this
because I gotta be honest I had never
heard of this person until like a week
ago so I'm learning most of the story
today too yeah she has 8.1 million
followers on Instagram damn 8.1 million
how long before she gets like a Croc
deal or something that's crazy I'm what
got a little knife giblet on there she
she's going to get a Croc with like um
NIV drip giblet and like a KN bloody KN
some gloves you know I guess I'm just
totally out of the loop on the on the
Gypsy loop I don't know oh she's about
to be like well you're in on it now I'm
in on the loop now this is one of the
strangest e celebrity situations of all
time I'd say yeah for real 2024 it's the
year of gypsy and uh Stanley Cups yeah I
got to admit when I started hearing her
name like two weeks ago the Gypsy Rose
it just sounds like it's like a it's a
fake name well like a and it's like a
Tik Tok handle or something right it's
like uh oh Gypsy Rose and Addison Ray
and you know the demilios I was think is
she on Tik Tok yeah she's on Tik Tok
there you go what did she post there she
yeah does she dance I haven't seen
dances oh my God 9.6 million followers
queen of course Tik Tok would be
flooding to her right Tik Tok is the
most degenerate people the people like
the general audience of Tik Tok is mad I
haven't been on there in a minute
Instagram reals is dude Tik Tok is ass
it's basically unusable I used to enjoy
this this um platform but it's been so
monetized it's unusable like every other
video is an ad and if it's not an ad
it's like a eligible for commission with
the shop it's like every video
yeah I tried to use it yesterday when I
was doing research and I had to have
Lena help me because when I went into it
it was just the shop I couldn't search a
hasht oh yeah they put you in the shop
yeah I feel like what are they doing
they're trying to make money as much as
possible before they get banned in the
USA
maybe sort of keep holding on uh Ryan
triller's gonna be tr's gonna make it
for sure I think it's sort of a
long-term plan that they had because the
way that they were able to exchange like
advertising like free advertising for
clout basically from these big creators
I mean before they're being paid for
them just the trends creators were doing
it for free so I felt like they always
planned on incorporating a shop they've
got to be having crazy Revenue right now
all right so let's see this one has 34
million hey also um my Tik Tok was just
hacked um we have a susp it's a crazy
world out here Gypsy you got to you got
to she probably doesn't know about two
authentication yeah it wasn't that
popular when she went in the CL we'll
let her know who it could be but um we
changed the password now um so I'm back
in control of the account right now
we're working with Tik Tok to get the
username and the profile picture back to
where it was like she has management
now sounds like it she's I can't even
get I can't find anyone to talk to a Tik
Tok Gypsy Rose got the main line in I
wonder if Austin McBroom reached out you
got
management excuse me sorry about the
random DM but do you have a are you
managed on o
yet true so don't freak out just yet I
am back in control um so shame on y'all
oh
[Music]
baby so anyway uh nobody this guy's bad
news I know
hey why do we think that why do you not
think that oh no freak out it's still me
um so just bear with me I don't know I
don't know any details about the romance
I mean I know only what they've put out
in the past few weeks so I also don't
know much well dude first of all I'm not
saying that nobody would love her that's
not what I'm saying obviously not she's
she seems like a really nice she's
pretty she's sweet resilient resilient
she's strong she don't well she well she
did need a man in the case of murdering
her I was going to say she don't need a
man but historically she has needed a
man
or Jesus I don't know I don't know I
mean I'm not wrong
right anyway
um but you know what I mean my feeling
is that if you watch this story and your
reaction is I want to date
her it's a little troubling you got a
lot of letters in
person yeah she had lots of love letters
mhm she only liked him cuz he was from
Louisiana wait she's dating Michael
Moore the
documentarian
wow yeah they met they're making a new
documentary I loved his work outside
Trump Tower bowling for Gypsy Rose oh my
God looks just like him I was thinking
more Peter Griffin but hey man it
yeah I see in between oh wow oh very
Peter Griffin actually here's the other
thing that I'm telling you I got the
warning sign on he's trying to get in
her videos right he wants he likes the
attention I have seen people talking
about that that's like he goes you know
he's trying to get in her Tik Tok here
they are they're making making videos
together already I mean and she when did
she get out of jail she served her time
like two weeks ago like two weeks de
29th a week ago just right now like
literally just right now and like
everyone is just again I just feel so
out of the loop with this like everyone
was like queued up everybody's waiting
for this moment yeah and like I I guess
again because of that show was super
popular I guess the the one that was
based on yeah it God the media landscape
is just so fractured now like with
everybody on their own show like I've
never heard of any of this before and
this girl is out of jail for two weeks
she has 9 million followers on Tik Tok
it's just crazy well they were like she
was on Euphoria or something they were
gearing up her social media I believe
before her release get ready cuz she has
a book and a new lifetime dock so she
was prepared to to tell her story when
she came i' love to know who's her
manager and like these
psychos that snuck into her life right
yeah there's some weasly motherfu it's
got to be the weas that
are on on her
team sh Knight's her manager isn't he in
prison uh yeah he is it doesn't mean he
can't no he's Shilling so yeah he has a
s too that's listen he has his ways he
got uh easy out of a contract someone
said did they talk about the grandpa
what's that about oh she was abused
sexually by her Grandpa when she was a
child all right excellent yeah detail
more more a lot of horrible things
happened is there something else we
missed about the grandpa horrible I was
looking to see if she had a manager and
the first article says strip club offers
Gypsy Rose a job after her release from
prison I did see that too that was
up no she's if she hopefully
doesn't have absolutely the worst like
bad faith evil manager she's going to be
very wealthy very soon
mhm let's see what this guy's like let
me get a feel on him Ryan let's play a
newly way game sounds good but you know
we're not really newly way let's call it
the newly together game okay I like that
awesome I like that what is gpy nickname
for what is gypsy's nickname for Ryan
cuddle muffin cuddle muffin that's sweet
it's sweet he is a cuddle muffin May a
good guy after all
that's he looks perfect oh his nickname
is Cuddle muffin oh he's a kind he's a
bright golden Soul he's probably better
than last
guy it does seem like an improvement
over the previous gentleman yeah has
this guy ever masturbated for 9 hours oh
this is a huge step
up or well they well in public or
otherwise hey that's
good as far as we can tell this is a
huge step up but time will tell
certainly did we get it
[Music]
right back to square
one appreciate the audio quality here a
lifetime you got this really nice scoop
sounds great sounds like it was filmed
on a noia
phone what's the question all right I'm
out I'm out on I have more stuff about
him you know stuff about him I have more
stuff oh let's go then so she posted
this sister love with her if you
go there we go next one her sister yes
that's her father's daughter what's the
deal with her dad so okay so the deal
with her dad is uh deei like told her
dad that Gypsy was really ill and then
as they started like qu they weren't
together when Gypsy was born they had
already broken up and um as the family
his the father's family started
questioning like whether or not she
needed these treatments they moved
away what so so they were like yo what's
the deal they s something was wrong yeah
Dee pulled Gypsy from they moved away
yes I
see and they're like well all right I
guess that solves that problem he's in
her life now and he wanted to be earlier
too but like Olivia said after they
moved away and he after questioning like
her medical conditions he didn't want to
push it too much cuz he feared that Dee
wouldn't let him see um gypsy at all
anymore okay I hope she has a nice uh
loving father that would be a nice he
seems to yeah he seems well adjusted
nice
wow oh God so this is Ryan Anderson this
is her new husband um he sent her
letters like we said uh she was
interested because he was from Louisiana
he reminded her of home and they look to
be very cut see but we're not sure yet
this is his Instagram profile I think
that that's adorable my name is Ryan
Anderson I'm from Louisiana I'm married
to the most beautiful the most wonderful
woman in the world Gypsy Ro they are
married in that video he just said
they're not married guess they are now
no I think they got married like a
couple years ago but he's saying like
they were married before but now they're
like oh he meant in the other sense cuz
they got married when not newly W okay
got it it they've been married married
prison in prison got it got
it
interesting
H okay yeah they got married July 21st
2022 okay all right here's the this is
the clip that matters I've seen this one
wait wait wait no no no go back not yet
yeah yeah that was after so she
commented on his selfie that he posted
and she said Ryan don't listen to the
haters I love you and you love me we do
not owe anyone anything our family is
who matters if you get likes and good
comments great if you get hate then
whatever because they don't matter I
love you besides they're jealous because
you are rocking my world every night
yeah I said it the D is fire happy wife
happy life this is a Serial
he wrote that he wrote that man he
took her phone he wrote that
so obsess with that I feel like
that's something Gypsy would write I
think she's a queen and I think she
did and he responded I think the D is
probably fire I agree if Gypsy said it
Gypsy knows you know what I mean wow he
responded to her who said I gave a damn
about what these jealous people say
anyway haha now come get it
baby oh
no and then now you can watch the clip
that's really
intense okay well thoughts Dan I mean
good for him good for him what can I say
50 Shades done guys I'm here with Gypsy
Rose herself the Celeb of the moment so
I know you have so many followers so
much love on social media but what I
want to know is what do you have to say
to the
haters um well you know can't bring me
down I'm on a high right now I'm living
my best life and y'all can't take that
from me and the D is
fire oh my God
we are
what is your message to your
haters
well just
saying I've killed once already dick
twoo cuz who are haters like law
enforcement the
Ops the
Ops all right all right so they're on a
press tour backdrops say all they ate um
the first clip is how she feels about
the fame and then the second clip is
just a funny new social media Fame is
next level I don't even comprehend it at
this point because for me I'm just
another face in the crowd so when I came
out of prison I didn't expect this giant
wave of social media you know I posting
selfies just like the next person would
or the next person not thinking anything
of it and before I know it has 2 million
views I'm just
like okay yeah you've got 6 million
followers I'd say so so what was your
reaction I mean it was just like
mind-blowing for you huh looks like she
got some decent dental work good dental
work yeah nice happy for her good for
her she's probably already pretty loaded
right because of the book and stuff you
mean it MoneyWise yeah they probably
gave her an advance on the book she she
made a book a long time ago right in
from prison or am I crazy or maybe know
oh she I don't think so that would be
under the law probably not allowed if
she made her own book yeah oh okay okay
cuz you can't profit from your crime
yeah if you're publishing your own book
that probably
interesting an adjustment like I I
didn't have social media for the longest
time so you know I'm having fun with the
Selfies and the Snapchats and all this
you're on everything you're on Instagram
Instagram Tik Tok Twitter I'm on
everything like we love her but when you
kind of step back a little bit and like
realize that she participated in a
heinous murder although you might say
that I don't know justifi I mean you
could justify it sure I mean she could
have well she tried to run away yeah
before and she was constrained
physically I don't it's it's it's a very
very layer what do you do if you're if
you've tried to run away she calls the
police brings you back she chains her to
the bed you go to the
police but that might
backfire if they don't believe you and
they just take back yeah one time I know
CPS came and visited the house and uh
Dee convinced them everything was okay
ah huh and as she became an adult when
she got closer to 18 her mom had a
lawyer draft up like a power of attorney
documents saying that yeah that Gypsy
was incap or incompetent mhm oh jeez
so if she had gone to the cops they
would probably just think she's crazy so
like I guess on one hand you step back
she took place with this really heinous
murder but on the other
hand she kind of had to M kill her she
does regret doing it though she say she
regrets it and the reason why she's
doing all of this publicity now is she
wants to get her message out and for
others who might be in a similar
situation she wants to just educ
inspiration yeah and and let them know
that there's other ways and they don't
have to that's what I was going to say
is there were definitely other options
but she probably didn't think that there
were what other options like I'm just
curious what what's a good scenario I I
mean again like it's easier said than
done especially when you're in a
circumstance like her but yeah I mean
probably reporting her mom to the police
for kidnapp you that backfire like so
easily I mean at this point she she was
an adult right yeah she was 21 during
the Murder She 21 they sign she could
just leave she could just leave it's
easy to say no that's that's what I
prefaced it with and she has this
psychopath that she's dating that is
clearly manipulating her and pressuring
her into uh you know wanting to act
violently or whatever but I mean let's
be real her mom being dead not a great
loss for Humanity yeah her mom seemed
like a real piece of poison real
bad H but yeah I mean there were
probably ways out for her that didn't
result cuz I mean ultimately on what
level was it a good idea she ended she
immediately got caught they were not
competent criminals and spent the next
like half a decade in prison right well
I don't know I I wonder what's what
would have been a better outcome if she
tried a different way or just kill her
and you know get get paid the 10 years
and then come out you a millionaire it
couldn't have that's kind of the best
outcome ever MH well and also in 20 7 a
doctor diagnosed her with munen by proxy
or at least um included it in the report
and everyone ignored it they didn't do
anything about it that's nuts
yeah it's always like that isn't
it she tried leaving it sounds like even
she had help from this guy
yeah Mama had to die she didn't have uh
Chad's saying she didn't have proper
documentation either her mom said that
her birth certificate was lost in
Katrina and a few other things
yeah what do we think let's do a poll
I'm curious do we like the murder do we
love that she killed her mom um okay do
we love that yes or no I think it's a
dou you it's a du dude now she's getting
she's getting Stacks her mom is toast
she's here watch this clip that I'm
sending you let's do that poll Dan uh
what's the poll are we loving that she
killed her mom Slay Slay
Queen the bll is are we loving that she
about how about this how about this it
feels inappropriate okay well okay I'll
I'll bring it down and Notch should she
have killed her mom yes no yes I'm not
I'm not doing that Paul I'm not doing
that make make one of these guys I did
see a tweet that feels icky I saw a
tweet that said she's the only person
person who actually served for slaying
mother which I thought was a crazy tweet
I just want the record to show that our
first episode back we had a poll that
says uh are you on the
Spectrum and and then the second episode
we have back that was a legitimate
question hold on I've got feedback
compare those things I heard that was a
bad poll because apparently on the
Spectrum doesn't just refer to autism it
could just mean like in general neurod
Divergent and there
that's not how I understood there
multiple
Spectrum yeah okay we're talking about I
think I got first poll of 2024 and it's
bad Dan well of course all right let's
write let's word this respectfully for
Dan should she have killed her mom that
wasn't that was what you just suggested
well I just didn't say yes and stuff and
like then we love it and all that I I'm
genuinely curious you know cuz if you
think through through it it kind of it
kind of makes sense how about did
Gypsy do the right thing Gypsy Rose
Victory Royale question mark or L I'm
kidding did she do the right thing
okay okay and of course murder is never
the right thing of course we are against
murder here at the A3 podcast to make
that clear and so is
Gypsy OJ how do you feel about
murder
Dan's a good man all right here we go uh
it's looking like about a 7030 split wow
in favor we are loving the although the
nose the nose are on the rise closer
to this is a wild pull two to one ratio
loaded question why no I think it's it's
did she do the right thing I
mean yeah I think that's
fair like sh you know
H people are we're riding for murder we
are saying yes to murder I myself as the
representative of this podcast have to
put my foot down and say no to murder
that is my official stance brave for
this show and
myself thank
you that's kind of crazy though 63% says
yes does that surprise you honestly we
learn more about this audience every day
so you guys scare me dude you guys scare
me
no I mean to be honest I might I might
vote Yes I didn't vote because I didn't
have the option you seemed like you were
leaning yes because way when you think
through it she had tried
already multiple ways to do it
non-violently yeah before you vote let
me think of the potential titles of your
haters and I mean listen it you could
it's self-defense like her mom was doing
violence on her on a daily basis medu I
was of the opinion that it was Gray I
was just offering the argument that um
perhaps there were still other options
on the table to say that it was the only
option I think is probably not true you
know if she just like shot her I bet she
might even have not been convicted she
one time picked up a gun and tried to
shoot her mom but it was a BB gun if it
had been a if it had been a crime of
fashion
killer she picked up a BB gun she's like
I'm going to kill you now and it was
just she shot her mom with a BB huh let
me get let me get you all the details on
that but I think I think if she just had
a gun by herself and killed her I feel
like she would have a very compelling
self-defense argument but I think the
the planning and the premeditation that
was that was a problem yeah the
boyfriend wanted to have sex with the
cadavers you know that was probably a
problem too it was when she tried to run
away the first time in
2011 huh wow while D went to extreme
length to keep her daughter Clos Dipsy
revealed she had shot her mother 10
times in her aim to escape but it was
with a BB gun oh my God that's a
horrible situation yes I think that you
could make the argument that Dee was
killing Gypsy oh she was yeah right I
think it's how she did it yeah I think
that's the problem I think we can say
the murder we love no no we can't say
that I be going a little too far don't
love it necessarily Mur we understand we
support gypsy's Freedom we with great
trepidation and uh careful
analysis love that she did that yeah I
agree however it was the method was real
was the problem was the
method I feel like one of them was going
to die true that Mom one of them
was going to die absolutely not Mom
absolutely one of them did the good
thing and U mommy dead and de you hear a
lot from the Mom's family and they all
describe her as like just this awful
person like none of them even wanted her
ashes they ended up dumping in the
toilet but
they what the for real but they
think that she killed her mom that Gypsy
mom killed her mom they think she tried
to poison her well she poison they
literally s to her rest piss Jesus they
pissed her ashes that's crazy so poison
the Stepmom wasn't there something with
the grandfather
too well Gypsy says that she was assayed
by her Grandpa when she was younger but
her stepmom um they claimed that she
tried to poison her but also that she
killed her own mother she she was crazy
perhaps a serial killer is she
Michael Corleone she's taking out the
whole family yeah three three would make
you a serial killer so she was on her
way huh yeah so it was just it was the
method yeah if she would have just done
like a good assassination just like a
hit you know what I mean clean one shot
well no I don't think that that would
help why because that's still
premeditated I think the difference is
if it it's a crime of passion if they
like I think the Premed trying to leave
the house and the mom is like physically
stopping her from doing it and it
escalates to a point where she kills her
that would be like an in the- moment
decision whereas If you hired a Hitman
or that's ESS what she did she not a
Hitman she did it
right hit that would be yeah that would
the premeditation part I think is what
at least from a legal perspec it was the
necrofilia stuff I said from a legal
standpoint but that never happened
apparently apparently not hopefully
[Music]
not damn
well well there it is we're almost we
got like we're one or two clips left so
sorry I have such a dicey joke I want to
say just but button it F too much yeah
yeah I was going to say and that's not
even the worst thing that happened to
her
body when her family flushed her
ashes the necrophilia but that didn't
happen so the joke doesn't really land I
would have it wouldn't even have been
the worst thing that happened to her
body
right that's pretty good
[Music]
no no you
it I mean I guess it's true getting
burned and then into ashes and then
being dumped in the toilet is pretty bad
but right but I mean if it is it fun is
my joke funny it's not really I'm sorry
it's not because how often do you get to
land because it didn't actually happen I
said if he did it it wouldn't have even
been the worst thing that happened to
her body so it's not that big of a deal
is my point uh free Gypsy I see Dan's
point if it happen it would have aligned
in a certain way yeah dude how I this is
the first time in my life I've had the
opportunity to do I understand the need
to say that because it's a Once in
a-lifetime lineup of things but if it
only happened which I'm glad it didn't
of course but right if it did though it
wouldn't it would have been a perfect it
would have been a perfect been the worst
for that hypothetical that didn't
happen I think also the fear of what you
were going to say kind of took the the
humor out of it cuz I was
afraid I'm looking at chat there seems
to be conf great conflict if fuses was a
nine yours was also a
nine right it was aidus nine that's not
aitous all right I'll take it I'll take
I'm just having fun with it has there
been a celebrity or influencer that's
followed you that's kind of made you
Star Struck um I haven't honestly check
my DMs I
am I am so flooded right now kind of let
it be I mean she seems like pretty well
adjusted for the life that she had which
is as up as you can possibly
imagine pretty
much that is
true like like she's like social she's
outgoing seems happy I mean that's
pretty impressive like when when did she
learn those social oh God not wait why
is she with the bachelor guy she was on
the podcast she went on was vile files
Nick vials from from The Bachelor he's
with what he got the exclusive I know
how come
on this May a bachor fan was her
boyfriend on the podcast too yeah yeah
looks like it how the did this guy
get the
exclusive this is a washed up ex
Bachelor and I don't remember the story
exactly but I remember him not even
being likable I liked him t i remember
he was on Andy season first and he came
in second and then he joined Caitlyn's
season halfway through and people hated
him because of that cuz like they had
never done that before and then he went
on Paradise and then he was The Bachelor
didn't he have okay all
right well good for him you got the
files
baby all
right go ahead watch the I just sent you
something in Discord this is a funny
clip with an
interviewer oh yeah I know this one this
is great I'm loving her Midnight's Sara
right now I'm oh wait no this isn't the
one I was think I was think I have the
other one too don't it karma has been
like my number one on my playlist
shocking shocking I am loving her
midnight era right now I'm loving it
karma has been like my number one on my
playlist H
shocking so the interviewer was out of
pocket
that's interesting interesting response
by the
yeah little judgy give her a
break doing you a favor lady where's the
other one where it's the final slide oh
good so what is this book documentary
this is she she came out with a book
called released conversations on the eve
of freedom and then over the weekend her
lifetime series premiered oh she's going
to get paid yeah so everybody go watch
well hopefully she's not actually a
murderer cuz she going to have like a
lot of resources at her disposal like
she could murder again easily I hope she
does I see what you're saying yeah she's
got a wacky boyfriend got a ton of money
I said no pickles she she hates pickles
experience okay this clip is
awesome my words that you are not alone
in in in this you know situation there
are other ways out um I did I did it the
wrong way um so you no don't say that I
did I I did something wrong and I I paid
my dues for it Oh you mean that part yes
the part of it you know that part of it
where you going
with dude but we're we're but you know
we're on your side I think actually here
in the H3 podcast we we would I we say
don't say that don't say that why was
she glowing purple she does with beauty
that must have been the ti Tok like
literally she no it's like super saan no
she's Ultra Instinct zal killer right
now Instinct yeah this you know
situation my words that you are not
alone in in in this you know situation
there are other ways out um I did I did
it the wrong way um so you know don't
say
that what did she think she was talking
about well probably the the abuse
earlier in her life or something related
to that like her mind just like skipped
over the whole murder part of the
story I I paid my dues for you mean that
part the part
she's like oh yeah that part where you
going oh
[Music]
yeah murder's wrong I do want to the way
that this is like a joke The Laughing
murder is very surreal the whole
situation this is a this is this is all
so much more than I thought again like
hearing this person's name over the last
couple weeks girl now you're well
informed now I I'm in the loop I'm in
the loop you've been filled in you been
filled in
yeah
unlike her mom's body no all right
should I button
that you should button this this episode
before enough necrofilia jokes before we
go way too far here all right so that's
all we and that's all I have to say
about that all right well thank you
Olivia thank you for another
comprehensive presentation our love to
gpsy hope she's okay but yes I will say
this blanket statement here I'm willing
to put murder is wrong NE it is never
right you are so brave here at the A3
podcast we oppose murder in all forms
for all reasons you are so
brave thank
you
uh I guess that's it probably 4:30 how
long we've been going uh going on three
and a half oh that's perfect
nice that's 320 more all right guys and
no more necrofilia jokes with peace and
love peace and
love but I you got to see like when do
you ever get that chance you know it
doesn't come up very often thankfully
mercifully I had to take yeah you got to
take risks in comedy ComEd comedians are
the last line of defense against the
woke M virus I had to take the corpse by
the horns as they say okay right yeah
cuz this is where where the woke meets
the wall
the woke meets the wall imagine me
saying that now after this whole conf
this is where the woke meets the wall
shut up bro it's just a and I am the
wall but like dude the people they okay
whatever I'm not going to get
Aller all
right well hopefully she just you know
happily ever after straight and narrow
from now on we'll keep our eyes on on
that boyfriend mhm yeah absolutely I
hope I hope no more murder yeah please
peace and love
when did she get out December 20 28th
morning after December 28th no more
murder thank you thank you thank you
thank you I live to like her Instagram
photos for real I wake up I like Gypsy
photo I go to
[Music]
bed
you cut out poor Avery's good joke there
I'll say Aver's I'll say Aver's in in
case it got cut out Avery Mega awesome
nerd said yeah necrofilia jokes are
usually Dead on Arrival anyway there all
laugh we were like and we were knee
slapping we were like who you
got him Avery and then Ethan went way
too far and we B but you can clearly
after today's episode you can clearly
and forcefully say that we are the last
line of defense yeah Yep this is where
the buff
stops cultur culture and Society is like
a Vortex swirling around
comedians everybody looks to
us wait she's pregnant someone said how
could she know that already she was not
pregnant a few days ago okay I think
that's random she's been out for two
weeks damn pregnant maybe we got aov
that had to be a conjugal thing I guess
that D is good man
magic all right listen Magic Stick
thank you everybody it was such a it was
a great episode we talked to fidus we
did the Gypsy Rose Saga was great wow I
think I'm going to watch that
documentary tonight we got lamb chops oh
my God I forgot even the best part of
the day I went and checked if it was
still out there yeah he not he bailed
yeah he's a trooper he he he really m
he's a good cook too damn yeah he is
shout
out well
friends uh thank you for watching it's
nice to be back that's Wednesday in the
can for y'all
MH um oh this is perfect I've missed
this song Thank you to the members you
guys make it all possible I appreciate
you all so very much and we'll be back
on Friday for another slam dunk action
packed yeah Banger of an
episode oh and we're bringing BTS back
for members that's right and the first
one is going to be really good right
yeah yeah and actually only the first
one though I thought of it I was
reminded right now because the Jersey
law man will be in it oh right it's the
um live show BTS yep that'll be great
cool but uh yeah see you guys on Friday
thanks for watching have a great night
everybody love
you
I'm on my own I just
where